and I have a required statement to read
as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order number
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the Judiciary Committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
and is expected to be held this
afternoon
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously glisten and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 that's
271-3600 or email HCS
leg.state.nh.us that's HCS
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce our staff person
today that's Jennifer for our committee
researcher who was assisting us with the
meeting and the technology
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting will be done
by a roll call vote
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
I'll begin and my name is Ned Gordon I
am at my home in Bristol New Hampshire
there's no one else in the room but my
wife is in the house and hopefully once
or twice during the morning
could you call the roll
representative McLean uh here I'm in uh
my home in Manchester New Hampshire
alone
representative Sylvia home alone in
Belmont
representative welper here alone I know
here with my dog and wife in Stratford
New Hampshire
representative Alexander good morning
here in Goffstown my roommates are also
in the house
representative rice
representative Mr Clark I'm sorry Mr
clerk um representative rice said she
joined in this afternoon
wow okay I'll have to think about that
thank you
uh representative Silber uh I am here
and uh in my home office in Guilford
with Millie my dog
yeah representative Greene
I'm here in my office in Hudson and my
wife is in the house
representative Kelly
I'm alone in Temple with my dog
representative Tosh
representative Tosh hello yeah I'm here
uh home by myself
representative trottier
good morning I'm here at my home in
Belmont in my office alone but I do have
three children in the house
representative Smith
um I'm in Durham alone
representative Burch
I am in West Milan alone
representative Oregon oh I too am in I'm
in Durham alone
representative diorenzo
I am here in my home office in Newmarket
representative sorry representative
Chase
in Rollinsford my father-in-law is in
the house
representative Kenny
thank you I am here um I am in my
apartment in Durham and my roommates are
around the house thank you
representative Langley I'm here home uh
home with my husband in Manchester
representative mcbeath
I'm in Portsmouth
um alone in my home office
representative page
Exeter in my own my home office alone
but family in the house representative
Simpson
I'm here in Exeter in my home and my
husband and Sons may be in and out of
the room throughout the day periodically
thank you Miss uh that and Mr chairman
that concludes the roll call and we're
almost off we're virtually all here
well we're mostly all here
mostly all here
representative rice did call yeah
yesterday and indicated that she had
another
she's a committee chair as well has a
conflict this morning and would be
unable to attend this morning
so I if we come to a point in time where
we do have items to discuss I would
perhaps discuss other items an executive
session but I won't take any votes until
this afternoon when I all the committee
are available here to take the votes
the uh the other issue that we have is
we have a very large
um
number of
bills to be heard where and where have
basically halfway through our bills I've
gone through and uh each all the bills
and it would appear that we would need
four hearing days and probably a a full
day to exec the remaining bills that we
have if we're able to get through all
our bills today to exec this afternoon
and which means five days
and we're supposed to have everything
out by March 11th uh if you look at the
calendar that only provides us with
about nine days of actual time
uh work time available between now and
March 11th to have hearings so I I have
informed the the speaker's office that
we do need time and we need
lots of time in the next couple of weeks
they did get back yesterday and
indicated that this coming Friday would
not not we we're having hearings this
Friday but the following Friday is
available and asked if we would uh take
that day
um I was reluctant because we're
scheduled to be have hearings on the
23rd which is Tuesday we're scheduled to
be in session on the 24th and 25th and
then that Friday is the 26th and that
would mean four days that week of
legislative duties
but I don't know uh that there's really
uh an option I probably need to take
that day
uh realizing that that's that's a big
burden for lots of people
and some people just may not be able to
be able to make it for the hearings
themselves but we wouldn't we wouldn't
exec anything and if in fact you found
yourself in circumstances where you
couldn't attend so I'm going to commit
to do that Friday I think because we
really need to do it
and hold hearings that day
and try to end a little bit at least a
little bit early in the afternoon so it
doesn't mess up your weekends
so uh just so you know Mr chairman I
have a county executive committee
meeting that morning
yeah from nine to eleven I have it on my
calendar from 9 to 11 and probably take
at least that long so you'll have to
have a substitute Clerk
okay
well that that that is that that that's
probably the biggest problem I face so
far is committee chairs getting somebody
else to do it so
um we'd have to find somebody else to do
it I think
I'm just saying
yep I don't have to be I don't have to
be part of this hearing business but
well I suppose I could
we are in the minority and uh
okay who's probably going to be um less
consequential than it might be here or
my import my my you get what I'm saying
I don't but you do I'm I'm uh I'm also
on the Stratford county executive
committee I'll have the same issue on
that Friday the 26th
okay thank you
okay uh we have three hearings scheduled
for this morning in the executive
session scheduled for this afternoon
our first hearing this morning is on
House Bill 135 requiring parties
responsible for pollution of a drinking
water supply to be financially
responsible for certain consequences of
that pollution
the primary sponsor
of this bill is a representative Bain
and is representative Bain available to
testify this morning
yes
can you hear me
I can we can
chairman and members of the Judiciary
Committee
I'm seven term Hillsborough District 20
town of Litchfield
I have to keep my comments short of
having an exact session in the education
committee right now
representative Rental South is also here
to testify
as you may wear places with Wells and
Litchfield Merrimack Bedford and
Manchester have been affected by water
pollution caused by PFA as pollutants
other towns may also be affected this
bill is not just for us but for any
future companies that are found to be
guilty of any pollution as you can see
the bill does the following responsible
party will be quiet to connect the
residents or business to a commercial or
Municipal Water Supply they shall supply
drinking water to those affected until
hookup is done if connection cannot be
made in six months the company will be
required to connect the whole house
filter and maintain such filter after
connect connection to commercial
Municipal Water the polluting companies
will pay the water bill for five years
based on the average uses for similar
residents of business or until a
property is sold thank you as I
mentioned I cannot take questions but
representative LaSalle's will so with
that thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for representative Bain no
I can't take questions
I have to go to education committee okay
representative lasalles
right
okay representative what's Alice you
have to unmute yourself
can you hear me we can
I'm thinking of writing a book it's
going to be titled can you hear me the
story of the pandemic
uh when I got up this morning to watch
the news it just so happened that the
channel I had it on was on an
infomercial that had to do with a
non-stick non-stick frying pan and they
showed a bunch of eggs
roaming around inside the the pan and it
was real nice to see those eggs none of
us want our eggs to stick to the fry pan
when we fry our our eggs in the morning
uh it's a wonderful thing
no one knows what the future may hold
with respect to wonderful products that
will help us out around our home and our
businesses
and so forth
um
we have a situation here in Litchfield I
represent Litchfield
Hillsborough 20.
and
when people moved into this wonderful
town that we call home
they built their homes or they purchased
their homes and many of them there's a
lot of Litchfield at least there used to
be that was not serviced by city water
and a lot of people in the northern end
of Litchfield toward Manchester
um there was there was no City water in
that area of town so everyone invested
or purchased a home uh with a well
everything was fine after that initial
purchase or putting in the well they had
very little expense other than
the electricity to run their pump
little did they know that we have an
industry just across the river
um that has been polluting
for
several years
and in fact continue to pollute today
now when it was discovered that this
company was polluted
there was provision made to supply these
folks with water so they didn't have to
drink the polluted water this is people
that have wells
which was most of the people in the
North End of Litchfield
and then over a period of a couple of
years
there was water lines that were that
were brought in so the people would have
city water
now these folks that live up there
expenses just went from virtually
nothing which was the electric cost of
uh running their world pump
to in many cases almost a hundred
dollars a month
for water
we have we have three problems with
water in Litchfield one is the
contamination one is the quality of
water but also the cost of the water
and it's not unheard of for people here
in Litchfield that have a hundred
dollars a month water bills we're in the
midst of a of a rate increase
fight right now but that's a different
story
seems to me that if a company is going
to produce a product
that they're going to sell to the public
like this non-stick fry pan
that you can purchase for 19.95
it's a certain amount of profit that's
built into that
it doesn't have it have to be a
non-stick fry pan it could be some
product unforeseen at this point
but some product in the future
it seems to me we need to build in a
certain amount of cost to that
if it turns out
that the process
that it needs to make this non-stick fry
pan or whatever other product
that it pollutes
the air the water
whatever
so the the purpose of this bill
is to
to make it so
that people who are who did not have a
water bill and now find themselves
through no fault of their own
to have upwards of a hundred dollars a
month in water bill
so that's the whole purpose of the bill
we limited it to five years because we
know there has to be some sort of a
limit I suppose
and
if the home is sold then the person who
purchases it all knows what they're
getting into
[Music]
so it's built into the value of the home
so with that all that all being said
I appreciate your time and I will take
questions uh
to my ability to answer
uh representative McLean
discover how Riders Supply Chain
Solutions thank you Mr chair and uh nice
to see you representative let's Alice
thank you for taking my question
um just just a quick question under the
provisions of this bill how is the
responsible party determined how is it
real I arrived at that this is the
responsible party and not the another
entity
first let me say I didn't realize you
could see me can you indeed see me
yeah we we can see you you have an older
version of Zoom so we had to promote you
the panelists okay if I would have known
you were able to see me I would have uh
primped up a little bit but but anyway
the the uh
the
provisions of the bill don't in the case
of saint gobane
away
a name that is Infamous here in
Litchfield
that they have they have owned up to
their
to their pollution
in the case of of another party
uh that would have to be determined
you want to follow up on that
representative McLean
well yeah I was just I was just
wondering is it Des makes that
determination or is it arrived at
through litigations
um I think I read in the bill that
there's already a provision that the
commissioner would make that
determination
yes that's true
any other questions for representative
project I guess representative the
question I have is can can this be done
retroactively in other words will the
law apply to somebody who has done this
in the past as opposed to only
prospectively somebody who does it in
the future
well the provision of the bill in this
case is anyone who has been harmed
uh so that would include ones in that
have been harmed up to this point
and I guess as a follow-up question I
have on it is
it seems to me that
you've decided what the remedy has to be
I'm presuming that this potentially
would be subject to litigation and
it would seem that
a homeowner might have different
remedies that they might want instead of
having water supplied they might want to
be compensated or have their house taken
and that they might apply to the court
to do
for a different remedy than this
provides
as well
concerned at all it just has a one
specific remedy and not other remedies
that might be available to somebody who
is harmed
thank you
well judge I'm not qualified to answer
that but uh
uh I'm sure it would have to be it would
have to be uh
litigated
are there other questions for
representative
yes representative
however taking my question
I hear that this applies to Litchfield
and I'm wondering if it applies to other
communities across the state if you've
talked to anyone any representatives in
other communities where this might apply
um
tell us about that
although although uh representative and
I both represent Litchfield and we do
have a certain polluter in mind it
wasn't meant certainly there are this
would also apply to to the Merrimack
which is an adjoining community in
Manchester at Bedford anyone who's
polluted but we're not restricting it to
just a single polluter any polluter
across the state when a when a business
comes into the state and they pollute
they should be held uh liable for any
damages that they do and that's the
intent of the bill had a really
um you know from from God I think other
questions
thank you for the testimony today well
thank you take care next time I'll dress
up
thanks or update your Zone
the uh
the uh that is the only person who
signed up are there other people who
wish to speak today if you do please
let us know
and I see that there are hands up
uh
and I see
uh Richard head
is Richard
um good morning I actually did not
register to testify on this bill okay I
thought I saw your hand now nope if I
did I apologize I may have hit it by
accident
okay thank you
and
Mike winsat from Des
yes good morning uh Mr chair can you
hear me
okay I can hear you
um my name is for the record my name is
Mike wimsat I uh work as serve as
director of the Des Waste Management
Division and I'm here to testify today
on House Bill 135 on behalf of the
department
um the department is not taking a
position on this bill
however upon review of the bill
um we did note that we thought it would
be helpful for committee members to
understand what the existing
requirements are and how that relative
to this issue and how they're
implemented and also to share some
concerns regarding some potential
unintended consequences that we think
might be associated with this bill
first of all under current law and
administrative rules parties that are
responsible for releases of regulated
contaminants that impact a drinking
water well are required to provide Safe
Drinking Water to those impacted
residences or businesses
and that includes uh providing and
paying for bottled water until the more
permanent solution can be developed also
um in cases where it's uh technically
and financially feasible to connect to a
nearby public water system we do see
that as the as the superior and
preferred alternative because it really
ensures that the impacted party will
have safe clean drinking water for the
foreseeable future but living in New
Hampshire is rural as we are there are
lots and lots of residents who are not
whose homes and businesses are not
located near a public water system so in
those cases there is an opportunity to
trying to connect
public water system to actually put in
what we call point of entry treatment
which I think the bill refers to as
whole house treatment where a filtration
full of water coming into the home from
the well is provided to to remove the
contaminant of concern and we need to
have that as an option because in many
cases if a water supply is a public
water supply is not nearby the cost of
extending a public water system can be
very very expensive right now we've been
doing a lot of work in the department on
water line extensions and we're finding
that
basically a mile of extending a water
main a mile is on the order of a million
dollars or more per mile so it's a very
expensive endeavor so um
and if so if someone does in install
in-home treatment
the responsible party under current law
and rules is required to pay for the
installation of that treatment as well
as paying the ongoing operation and
maintenance of the filters or whatever
the system might be for the um for the
duration of treatment
um so we have I guess some concerns
about potential anatomic consequences
and they're really three that we
identified
the first one is related to the
requirement to install the point of
entry treatment
um if if connection to a public water
supply system can be completed within
six months and um there's really two
reasons we have some concerns about that
first it's unclear from our read of the
bill whether that requirement is
intended to be a temporary remedy and
that in all cases connection to a public
water supply system is still going to be
required
um but but we don't think that that's
practicable for the reasons stated
earlier a second when a connection to a
public water supply system is determined
to be the preferred solution it often
takes more than six months to do the
necessary design work there may be a
short extension of the water main and
then of course the connection from the
current to the home and the in-house
Plumbing this needed to be done so we
think it's very common that it will take
more than six months in our experience
to connect to a public water supply
and the concern we have is that the bill
would require them that in-home
treatment also be installed and we're
concerned that if that were the case in
many cases even even if there is a
nearby water system it is more expensive
to connect to the water system than to
install in-home treatment
many times responsible parties will
elect to to
to basically select this more expensive
option because they want to really put a
period on their responsibilities they
want to they don't want to have a
long-term lingering administrative and
and uh and and caretaking responsibility
to uh pay for in a range for uh uh
operation maintenance and filter changes
and that sort of thing so they're
willing to spend more money up front to
put a period on it if you will and you
know put in a clear end to their
responsibilities to comply
so we have a concern that if the if the
six-month rule were to be implemented
that if they're going to have to put on
in-home treatment anyways
um that they may just say well we put on
in-home treatment we're not going to
elect to do a connection to a public
water system and we think that would be
an inferior solution over time for
people whose Wells have been impacted
um and we think that that requirement
might kind of reduce their willingness
to comply and be be cooperative
the second concern we have is that the
five years month of monthly water usage
bills and we're very familiar with this
the agency was intimately involved with
you know requiring single Bain to
provide Connections in Litchfield and
Merrimack and Bedford and they spent uh
uh tens of millions of dollars to design
and Implement that system
um
but I think that it's important to
understand
um
The Five-Year water bill may be a
significant distance Center for parties
to comply and part of that is that while
we do have a large corporation that had
the means to design and Implement and
construct a water line system for
hundreds of homes in Southern New
Hampshire
the more common example is a small
number of homes impacted by a small
business or in many cases a municipality
and so concern we have is that um when
you with those folks we we've
manipulating this this requirement these
requirements for many years and we
actually get pretty good compliance but
it is a significant burden for these
small businesses or municipalities to
comply with the expenses associated with
connecting to water or providing in-home
treatment and paying for the long-term
operation of Maintenance are a
significant financial burden if you add
on top of that they also have to pay
five years of the water bills we're a
little bit concerned that some folks
just may say well we're going to fight
this so we're just not going to be
cooperative or we're simply going to
walk away because it's just too big of
an ask so we are very pleased that we do
have a pretty good record of getting
responsible parties to comply with the
existing requirements and we do have
some concerns that adding this
additional significant expense
um to the to their responsibilities may
have the you know the unintended
consequence of causing them to be on
cooperative so um we're certainly we
understand where this bill is coming
from and we are certainly be willing to
work with the bill sponsors so
try to address some of the concerns that
we've raised uh but we wanted to share
that with you this morning and with that
I'll uh be happy to take any questions
yes representative Silber thank you uh
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I noticed that in the on line
15 it talks about 14 15 it talks about
the installation of a whole house water
filter and the maintenance of such
filter
without any standards isn't there some
incentive for whoever is the the uh the
pro person or the entity that's caused
this problem to go out and get the
absolute cheapest whole house water
filter as opposed to a high-end Reverse
Osmosis System
well in practice with the contaminants
that we're usually dealing with there's
usually sort of a presumptive technology
that will do the job and we do work with
um the homeowners and the responsible
parties to make sure that you know
Quality Systems that are capable of
treating the effective contaminant of
the involved contaminants are installed
we haven't I I would not say that we've
experienced that that situation in in in
our experience in implementing this are
there any rules of the discussion to a
follow-up
follow up is there any rules of the
department that set the standards for a
whole house water filter that would
comply with this
I don't think there are any rules that
are explicit that talk about that I mean
basically the rules require that safe
alternate water be provided by the
responsible party and so what that
typically means is that if it's going to
be in-home treatment if the treatment
technology and the equipment be capable
of effectively treating and there is
there is a requirement and as part of
that operation of Maintenance that the
responsible party is required to pay for
on an ongoing basis that also includes
sampling of those treated water to make
sure that it is being effectively
treated so that that does get confirmed
through the implementation of these
requirements
thank you very much
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so when it comes to
the determination of responsibility
um just to follow up on that a little
bit so the commissioner will make the
the finding as to who the responsible
party is and does that responsible party
have a right of of repeal uh in in the
system or do they have to go to court to
do that
yeah
so sure so the um I mean under the bill
it does say the commission would make
that determination in practice under
current law and Rule
um these requirements are typically
administered through my division the
waste management Division and any
decision that we make in the division is
subject to appeal by the uh to be heard
before the waste management Council and
then if the party is unsatisfied with
the with the disposition of it by the
council they can appeal to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court that's that's
how appeals of our division decisions
are are handled
[Music]
representative Chase
like right now you say this is deferred
to waste management if this bill went
through and then it would be given to
the commissioner to D redeem that is
that going to cause problems for you or
are you going to have to work together
what's that going to do for a change and
that the way things are working right
now
well that that may be going someplace
I'm not qualified to comment on I will
tell you that lots of statutes um in in
state government in New Hampshire do
refer to the commissioner of the
department but in practice the work of
the department gets administered through
its divisions and there are explicit as
that gets divided up essentially
um as those divisions make their
decisions the appeals of those decisions
typically go through you know in in the
case we have three divisions and
essentially each one has a council
associated with it in the appeals of the
decisions with some exceptions for
specific laws are typically heard by
their respective councils so I I I'm not
sure the answer to that but I I think
there are lots of examples of where the
statute cites the commissioner as a way
of describing the department but in
practice the the decisions that get made
get made at the division level and the
appeals of those decisions go through
those appropriate uh channels okay
okay
yes representative Simpson
hello thank you for taking my question
um how long does it typically take to go
through the process from start to finish
to remedy a home water supply
well I I would say that it varies you
know and part of it depends upon the
level of cooperation by the responsible
party
um if we if we take out if we assume
that we've already identified a
responsible party and that they they
have accepted that they are a
responsible party once we make a request
or once we I guess the thing that
happens immediately is if we typically
what happens is we we identify that we
have contaminated groundwater somewhere
and we look around to see what
residential or businesses Wells might be
impacted and we immediately go out we
either require the responsible party or
we go out and do the sampling to to see
if those Wells are impacted once we
identify that a well is impacted above
standards
um we basically require that bottle of
water be provided immediately to the
people who are impacted so that
generally happens very very quickly
um but once that happens we also say
well now that you've got bottled water
and you've addressed the immediate
concern about the Wild Water being over
standards you now need to provide
alternate water under the law and so
then that you know first thing to do is
look around and say well is there a
public water system that can easily be
connected to the home
um and if that happens if the answer to
that is yes that often takes several
months because it means that now you've
got to get an engineer to concise well
where is the water line do we have to do
a short water line extension we need to
design uh you know figure out how we're
going to run from the curb stop through
the home through the property
um to the home and then get contractors
on board to do that so if everyone's
really Cooperative you can do that in a
couple of two in probably two to six
months I would say
um if there isn't cooperation then
obviously it gets delayed in other cases
we you know I guess if we take the sink
of an example that was a huge water line
project that was many many miles of the
water main that had to go through a
process success of design reviewing the
whole route you know an engineering
design and then going out to bid and
getting contractors it took a couple
years from the time that we and again
single Mains was a little complicated
because we were negotiating with them a
huge project they were going to spend a
whole lot of money to address a whole
lot of wells and we were still
collecting data from Wells we're still
collecting data from Wells today because
the water line projects that occurred
um in the in the early going as a result
of that project were based on the
standard of 70 parts per trillion for
the contaminant of concern but last
summer our standard was lower for the
same contaminant to 12 parts per
trillion so now they're doing further
sampling to evaluate Wells that that are
impacted so that that's kind of a that's
an outsized project that perhaps is not
a good example if you set that aside
that's very unusual in our program we
didn't have anything like that I mean we
had over 65 square miles of Aqua for
impacted by that site which is just
unheard of in the state
more typically we're talking about you
know one to ten homes that may be
impacted by a contaminated site so but
even for that if you had a water system
that was nearby but not already right in
front of the street in front of the
homes there would be several months you
know perhaps a year even involved in
designing the uh the water line and then
going out to bids and getting it
construction so probably you know eight
months to two years for a significant
project in that category
are there any other questions from Mr
Wilson
yes representative De Lorenzo
thank you for taking my question um
had the sponsor of this bill
um consulted with you on the writing of
the Bill of the drafting of the bill
no I don't believe that the department
had any Communications with the
sponsored service okay thank you
any other questions
seeing then thank you Mr wimsat for your
testimony thank you
uh the next person I see with their hand
up is David Creer
hi good morning uh thank you for letting
me speak David Greer I am director of
public policy at the business and
industry Association uh Bia uh sorry I
couldn't uh sign up in time to get on
the official list uh thank you for
letting me speak now uh so Bia is
opposing this bill
um because of a number of issues that we
see that present uh unfair burdens thank
you
um
first and I think probably the the most
glaring issue that we have uh has kind
of alluded to earlier is that the bill
states that whenever the commissioner
finds that a public or private
Corporation or other entity has violated
the provisions of this chapter uh that's
when they become subject uh the issue
with this is that it allows the
Department of Environmental Services to
conduct their own investigation
determine what has happened and then
issue a violation and a remedy require a
remedy without any due process so
there's no adjudicative proceeding uh
before any of that occurs
um you know as alluded to before by Mr
wimsat if the business uh doesn't like
the outcome of that they have to then
appeal uh and if they don't like that
they have to appeal again to the Supreme
Court so there's no due process before
um the violation is found uh
additionally
um
uh has also alluded to the six-month
requirements in the bill uh is pretty
unrealistic for a lot of areas in New
Hampshire it would be tight even if they
are close uh to a public or private
water supply system so that would make
it pretty uh close to Impossible in many
situations for businesses
um
what else um
there's also uh the issue where
running a private uh well in your house
is at not free it does actually have
costs associated it with maintenance and
I think alluded to electricity bills
this bill does not account for the
difference between what you would
normally pay for your water on a private
system versus the water bills that would
be part of a public or private water
supply system
so those are just a few of you know the
bigger issues that we saw that would
create unfair burdens on New Hampshire
businesses so we appreciate you letting
us provide our testimony and I'd be
happy to take any questions
yeah are there any questions
from the members
seeing no questions thank you for your
testimony today thank you
next person with their hand up is
counselor Barbara healing
can you hear me we can thank you so much
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
Judiciary Committee I am Barbara Healey
I am one of the town councilors for the
town of Merrimack and I am speaking in
support of house bill 135.
as time has gone by researchers are
finding that these forever chemicals are
causing more and more harm to people
they have found potential adverse Health
impacts associated with pfas exposure
including liver damage thyroid damage
decreased fertility high cholesterol
obesity hormone suppression and cancer
also these chemicals can pass through
the placental barrier thus passing to
The Unborn and can be passed through
breast milk to infants
Merrimack and the surrounding
communities of Bedford Litchfield and
Londonderry have been dealing with the
pfas contamination issues in the
surrounding areas of Saint gobain
performance Plastics since 2016. this
contamination has been found in our air
soil drinking water surface water and
groundwater
we have had to deal with our private
Wells and our town being deemed unusable
along with the wells belonging to the
Merrimack Village District which
supplies the water to merrimat and being
shut down for high contamination rates
some private well owners have been
hooked up to public water but many are
still receiving bottled water after five
years with no insight as to when they
will have any remediation
I speak in favor of House Bill 135 today
especially regarding section three if
the connection required in paragraph one
cannot be made in six months or less the
public or private Corporation individual
partnership and or other entities shall
pay for the installation of a whole
house filter and maintenance of such
filter people with contaminated wells
should not have to make do and live on
bottled water for five years or more
waiting for a corporation to make a
decision understand that this means
storing and disposing of pallets of
water bottles when delivered
timely action needs to happen so that
the water coming out of their faucets is
clean and drinkable
as soon as possible again thank you for
this time to speak
thank you are there any questions for
the counselor
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
there is someone whose name is Laureen
who has their hand up and wishes to
speak
hi good morning
um thank you Barbara for speaking um I
was listening I hadn't signed up to
speak for this bill but I was kind of
surprised because here in Merrimack we
have a rep Jose sponsor a co-sponsor
this bill she's not present and I
thought she would be giving a little bit
more of the Merrimack story and I also
have a rep who I believe is part of this
committee who is not present so given
that I felt compelled to speak so I
wrote in support of this bill could you
could you just identify yourself first
so we know who you are so sorry I'm so
sorry it's just that kind of morning
isn't it Laureen Allen I'm a Merrimack
resident of many many years I'm also the
co-founder of Merrimack citizens for
clean water which brings citizens and
legislators and town people and or water
department all together to talk about
this problem as we've done since 2016.
many of you are familiar we've been all
over the news so um my thoughts on this
bill is when I read it you know it's a
good attempt I I can see the intent it's
far from perfect the six months as
Barbara said it's not realistic
um The Five-Year you know it's almost
like a wish list Stick it to him wish
list but my point is
um we need to find a way to work with
this bill
um maybe to amend it because the point
is
um responsibility
so senko Bain has always promoted all
the things they've done but what you
don't hear is there's been this
continual pushback this denial of
responsibility for both public Wells and
private Wells uh in October 2019
seven to eight hundred Wells were
identified as their responsibility those
homes are the latest chapter of homes
that are without remediation plan uh
last month over 300 more private Wells
were just added primarily in Bedford in
Londonderry so we have over 1100 maybe
1300 at least Wells that they have on
the list at this point there is no plan
in sight we have asked them in a
community advisory committee meeting a
rough timeline anything and they say
things like we're still assessing the
situation so it's very frustrating to
Residents and my goal here is just to
speak for all these people because
maybe they don't know how to log on or
that this process is even taking place I
try to inform them but It's Tricky so
this this bill
um in theory seeks to send a message
that we do expect not only
responsibility for What the residents
did not cause we know who caused this
problem in this particular area but in a
timely manner to fix this to connect
these folks to a safe drinking water
supply there are people one family I
heard from gets hundreds of gallons of
bottled water every month the Plastics
the storage the disposal it's absolutely
not okay for people to live like this
for so many years currently there is a
vast vast area of contention that they
are reducing liability by stating that
they don't want to take responsibility
for hundreds more Wells so again this
bill is less than perfect uh Mike
brought out some very good points
Barbara out another point but I think
you know I would ask that perhaps you
work with it and you look at this and
reach out and um and find a bill that
you can put forward that sends a message
to responsible parties that we expect
them in some what of a timely matter you
know Mike said two to six months uh a
project could be complete a good example
of that is Amherst uh in 2016 a company
named TCI a competitor of Saint Cobain
also working in fabric coding was deemed
responsible for over a hundred private
Wells they were hooked up to pennichuck
water in a very very Swift manner here
in Merrimack Bedford Litchfield
Londonderry parts of Hudson parts of
Manchester hundreds of homeowners are
still waiting and we have no commitment
to a plan thank you
thank you for your testimony today are
there any questions
yes representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question at this point has
anything been resolved with any of the
well save in the first seven eight
hundred that were found
to help the situation right now in in
the Merrimack area
Des is awaiting Saint Albans
um analysis of the data is what we've
heard month after month after month so
in October in 2019 we had the new mcls
in the state which put pfoa at 12 parts
per trillion which was fabulous uh what
happened at the end of that year uh by
December 31st Sanko Bain sent out a
notice to the state saying that they
were stopping their investigation and
stopping their water sampling so
everything came to a halt because the
mcls as you may recall were challenged
in court and the judge put a stay so our
Senate did work on that issue last
summer thankfully and they have just
recently picked up
um you know so they spent over a year
doing absolutely nothing when they knew
they knew what they were going to have
to do so the issue is you know I'm not a
real big believer in overly you know
we're New Hampshire we don't want to
kill people with laws we all agree on
that but um they have too much wiggle
room here
uh and this can go on at least all of
this year I think we're looking at well
into 2022 before they have an action
plan and then it's going to be another
year before they start to implement it
so that two to six months you know has
been done in the past the original round
in Merrimack back in 2017 they pushed
that out two years before they worked on
it and we had 45 homes with private
wells in this town that weren't even on
the list despite Des stating clearly
desanko Bane that they were their
responsibility those homeowners were not
hooked up to public water till early
2020. absolutely not acceptable so our
journey has been if you knew it you'd be
astonished
okay any other questions
saying none again thank you for your
testimony today
and I don't see any other hands up
uh for
people to testify
though I will call the uh I will close
the hearing on House Bill 135.
I would note that
there were nine then 91 people who did
sign up in support of the bill
and only two people who signed up in
opposition to the bill
we just have a couple of minutes and
we'll call the hearing together on our
next bill
thank you
how much
I will just know before we begin on
House Bill 236
that on this bill there were 99 people
who signed up and support and 11 people
who signed up in opposition
we do have eight people who have signed
up to testify
and none has asked for more than five
minutes so I will do my best to hold
them to the five minute
I'll just keep track of tonight
and I'll call the hearing to order on
House Bill 236.
this is an act creating a statute of
limitation on civil actions relative to
damage caused by parafloric
alkyl and poly
oral alkyl substances
the primary sponsor is representative
Vale as representative Vale
available to testify
yes I am can you hear me as well thank
you okay great thank you good morning Mr
chairman and members of members of the
Judiciary Committee thank you for your
consideration of House Bill 236 this
bill was previously filed and had broad
support in the house last year it never
made it to the Senate due to the state
of emergency
pfas chemicals are groups of thousands
of compounds that are biocumulative
environmentally persistent they are used
to repel water and oil by an industry
that creates
non-stick Coatings such as Teflon and
waterproof Fabrics such as Gore-Tex and
also the creation of firefighting
turnout gear and firefighting foam these
compounds pres are also present in
carpeting food packaging and many other
products that require water to be
repelled
because of the slippery nature of these
particles they quickly enter the soil
they do not dissolve and they're called
Forever chemicals for that reason the
town abiding my district is in Nashua
um is within a
has within it a zone of contamination
where pfas is present
this is presently
a 4.5 mile radius around the
saint-gobain performance plastic plant
on DW Highway in Merrimack people who
live within the zone are not able to use
drinking water from their well or from
certain Municipal Wells that are
currently being upgraded with filtration
systems in longitudinal studies evidence
implicates that pfas impacts fetal
development increases risk of
Developmental and endocrine disorders
where home hormones depression occurs
pfas is linked to cancer kidney disease
high cholesterol and tumors particularly
in small animals it also concentrates in
breast milk affecting a mother's ability
to nurse their child due to the
Persistence of pfas and nature and it's
con consideration to be permanent
contamination there is a half-life of a
million years for these particles
the particles are found in the blood of
99.7 of Americans and their presence has
dislodged our environmentally our
environmental safety permanently
cities and towns and taxpayers are being
stuck with the remediation Tab and the
health problems
polluters are seeking permission to keep
polluting without filtration installed
that is intended to mitigate releases of
pfas compounds into the air as emissions
the longer the filtration is delayed the
more people become exposed
for over a longer period of time
not providing information to Residents
about the impact of their manufacturing
on their water in establishing a cleanup
plan
polluters have somehow been able to
manipulate and dominate the EPA for
varying weeks of time over many decades
this allows manufacturing with pfas to
continue with no end in sight
why expand the statute of limitations we
need more time
to calculate the scope of harm that has
been done to townspeople and to address
impact on specific vulnerable groups
such as elderly children pregnant women
and women who are nursing this is
particularly important due to the
latency of illness onset
to identify victims and get a sense of
the scope of the problem in all of New
Hampshire
to protect municipalities from bearing
the cost and health effects of
industrial pollution
to delineate a true zone of
contamination defined by a perimeter of
Wells that are clear of toxic levels of
pfas in other words levels that are
within the current allowable maximum
contaminant level
and also to provide vital education to
Citizens and medical providers of this
region and to help them understand how
to reduce harm and evaluate individual
extent for future care
before I close I want to say that the
most impelling argument and support of
this bill is a position that our
nation's nation's firefighters are now
in due to pfas exposure in their turnout
gear and firefighting foam
we have one million one hundred and
fifteen thousand firefighters in the
United States we have thousands of fire
stations in America and we have not
begun to test and to study and to begin
remediation
with the exception of
the um the site at the former peace Air
Force Base which was addressed through
Department of Defense funds
there is a long way to go before we know
what is needed and who it who needs it
especially we when we consider the cost
of the camp contamination and for that
reason we'd like to
extend the pfas injury to six years the
statute at this time
representative Maureen Mooney is also
signed up to speak and she will be
arriving after she presents her bill in
another committee
so I would ask that you please
um
be aware that she'll be coming in late
with that I will take any questions you
may have but I in part that the
following speakers
may be about to address the questions in
their testimony and if not may be able
to answer your questions with better
death and as I said I'd be happy to take
any questions you may have
thank you representative Alexander do
you have a question
um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Vale for taking my
question
um you mentioned this past
um the house last year can you just give
me the bill number of that
I don't actually have the bill number
right here I it was not my bill it was
filed by another person
thank you representative Kenny
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um so you you made the case that uh the
statue of limitation should be increased
and I'm sorry if I missed it uh what is
the current statute of limitations
as in any personal injury
if we would assume that it would be
three years
um
as as any other personal injury
thank you so much
you have any other questions for
representative Vale
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you for the questions
representative David Muse
is representative Muse available
uh yes I am okay I'm here
you may proceed
thank you very much my name is
representative David Muse I'm from
Portsmouth and I'm here today to speak
in favor of HB uh 236.
um
I'm not a lawyer uh but I have seen over
the course of my life how our legal
system uh definitely can skew in the
favor of large well-heeled corporations
to the detriment to people who are
exposed to contamination that was caused
by some of these companies
in the late 1960s I lived in Woburn
Massachusetts at a time when tap water
in our neighborhood turned brown and
started smelling like chemicals
unlike a lot of the other mothers in the
neighborhood my mom absolutely refused
to let us drink it we wound up all
gaining a little bit of weight over the
course of the next two years because we
drank a lot of fruit juice that had a
lot of sugar in it
um but these were the 1960s and many of
my friends mothers mixed the water with
Kool-Aid to hide The Taste and to hide
the smell
so in my neighborhood kids kept drinking
that water and it's the 1970s started to
Dawn kids in my neighborhood started to
get leukemia
the litigation that rose out of the
deaths in Woburn was based around
allegations that companies disposed of a
chemical called tce illegally
but in the case of pfas plaintiffs are
often trying to recover damages from
companies that sold or used these
chemicals in the broad light of day for
applications like firefighting foam for
things like Scotchgard for things that
just are part of our everyday lives but
they did that with the knowledge that
these chemicals were toxic and that they
had the potential to to contaminate
groundwater
um both tce and pfas can prompt acute
reactions when you when you ingest a
large amount but pfas is actually more
Insidious because extremely small
amounts can do a great deal of harm
worse as representative Dale mentioned
the human body has no way of actually
getting rid of pfas once it's been
ingested
so even if you're just dealing with a
few parts per trillion uh over time and
over a period of years uh a situation
arises where you just accumulate more
and more and more pfas in your body
this is actually why so many people in
my community are concerned about the
contamination at peace for many years
people in Portsmouth and surrounding
communities worked at the trade point
and brought their kids to daycare there
only to learn that the simple Act of
drinking water put them at risk for
health conditions with timelines that
can vary and that sometimes can take
years to develop
in just a few weeks a testing program
run by the federal government is going
to resume and that's going to let many
more people know conclusively uh and
some of them for the first time what
levels of exposure to pfest they
actually have in the systems and the
systems of your kids
so with HB 236 if these people
eventually suffer Health damage as a
result of their exposure the clock of
litigation wouldn't start from the time
when uh the water was first contaminated
it would actually start from the date
that the plaintiff discovers that he or
she has been harmed
extending the statute of limitations to
six years is also appropriate for a type
of chemical exposure where the physical
consequences of harm can take years to
manifest themselves one of the things
that's come to light just recently is
that the harm that pfas or some types of
pfas can do to your immune system
actually make you more vulnerable to
cobit so we have people who may be
living with a long-term consequences of
covet should they catch it
that may be much more severe than other
people might experience and it's because
their immune system may have been harmed
by these chemicals uh to my knowledge at
least two other states have passed a
similar law and I would love it if you
put us on the road to making New
Hampshire uh the Third thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for representative Muse
yes
representative McLean
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so in in the the a
question asked of the prior speaker was
um answered in that the statute of
limitations has gone from three years to
six years
um but can you answer does the current
statute of limitations also begin with
discovery of harm or resist something as
well that's new with this bill
I believe it I believe in the case of
this bill it begins with a discovery of
harm so that's when that's when the
clock starts uh so for instance with
pfas
um one of the issues is you may not know
for years that you've actually been
exposed you may not feel physical
symptoms
um but then one day uh uh you wind up
going to the doctor uh with it with a
condition uh that's making you ill
that's making you sick they start
running some tests and one of the things
that they discover is not only do you
have a condition that's associated with
with pfas but you also have high levels
of chemicals of these chemicals in your
blood what what's different in many
cases about pfas exposure is there isn't
necessarily an immediate toxic reaction
so unlike the 1960s when when I was
living in Woburn and we could actually
see the water coming through the Taps
was brown and it smelled bad uh and it
even it even uh made the sheets that my
mother hung out in the clothesline it
actually made made them blow apart in
the wind it would actually deteriorate
the uh the materials that the Sheets
Were Made of so we could see that it was
doing harm and what's Insidious about
these chemicals is that in so many cases
you can't see the harm that they're
doing and that and the quantities can be
very very small
thank you
yeah thank you
um so yeah I can see that in the
legislation as presented
um the clock starts ticking with the
onset of the harm and the discovery my
question was just is that in itself a
departure from the existing law
um or is that in in in does that go
along with where the existing law is
already my understanding is that it is
but uh that's something I think that I I
may not fully understand so uh I would
suggest asking maybe some of the
follow-up speakers that question
um I'm not 100 sure so I don't want to
give you a flat out yes that it is my
assumption is that's the case though
thank you
any other questions for representative
Muse
thank you for your testimony today
thank you we also have representative
Robert Healy is he available
yes I'm available can you hear me we can
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
Judiciary Committee I'm Representative
Bob Healey of Merrimack and I am
speaking as a co-sponsor and in support
of house bill 236.
Merrimack and the surrounding
communities of Bedford Litchfield and
Londonderry have been dealing with the
pfas contamination issues in the areas
surrounding this a Cobain performance
Plastics facility since 2016.
this contamination has been found in our
air soil ground and drinking water
we haven't
had to deal with the private Wells being
deemed unusable and Wells belongings of
Merrimack Village District being shut
down for high pfas contamination rates
while Saint Cobain has agreed to pay
some of the cost and current news
thank you public Wells and provide
bottled water or connect Wells
well owners public water this has been a
long and laborious process for those
affected people and many are receiving
bottled water at this time
as time has gone by
researchers are finding that these four
other chemicals are causing more and
more harm to people
they have found
potential adverse Health impacts
associated with pfas exposure include
liver damage thyroid disease decreased
fertility high cholesterol obesity
hormones oppression and cancer
as further study of Maximum contaminant
levels of these chemicals evolves our
Citizens need additional time to
identify the physical damage to their
bodies
protections under the law
so today I speak in favor of House Bill
236 extending the statute of limitations
to six years after the damage is
discovered thank you for allowing me to
testify today
thank you are there any questions for
representative Healy
thank you for testifying today thank you
we don't see representative Mooney has
joined on the list of attendees
so we'll call on the other witnesses
that I have
uh Wendy Thomas
you could
is Wendy Thomas available
yes I am now
can you hear me we can all right thank
you uh Mr chair esteemed colleagues of
the Judiciary Committee
uh I am former representative Wendy
Thomas from Merrimack
and I come before you in support of
House Bill 236 a bill that will lengthen
the statute of limitations for pfas
related injuries I just want to clarify
one thing before I begin this bill was
filed last year while I was a State Rep
but it was not heard
so um there seems to be a little
confusion about that it was filed um in
last year
this bill arose from participating in
and testifying at the hearing for Maine
Bill 1544 which extends the statute of
limitations for pfas related injuries
from three years to six years
the main bill is based on a
recommendation from the governor's pfas
task force
bill in Maine came about because of a
local farmer who used pfas contaminated
biosolids which is another name for
fertilizer on his farm
he didn't know it was in the solids his
cows didn't know pfas was in the grass
That Grew From the solids and they only
realized it when the cow's milk was
tested and it was found to contain high
levels of pfas
the farmer lost his herd his farm and
his business because it had been more
than three years since he had used the
solids and there was no Financial
recourse
many farms and even family gardens in
Maine where a sludge had been spread
have also not been tested the extent of
the damage remains unclear
and when they were contaminated is even
more unclear
New Hampshire house bill 236 attempts to
correct this problem particularly in
areas most hard hit with pfas
contamination those being the Seacoast
and Merrimack it extends a statute of
limitations for pfas-related injuries
only from three to six years
the legislation would provide plaintiffs
six years to file a lawsuit from the
time they knew or should have known that
pfas could re could be responsible for
their injuries or damages
before he died The Honorable dick Hench
and I worked on the wording of this bill
honorable hinge signed on as a
co-sponsor living in a pfest impacted
Community he knew how important it was
to let science catch up with what was
happening
when I was not re-elected representative
hinch made sure that two other
representatives from our town
co-sponsored and supported this bill
pfas is measured in parts per trillion
it bioaccumulates which means that it
collects in your body
much like the straw that breaks the
camel's back too much pfest tips your
body over into illness it may take a
little bit of time it may take years
pfas injuries can also be passed On to
the Next Generation
babies can be born with learning
disabilities and medical illnesses as a
result of the mom-drinking contaminated
water during pregnancy
here's what we do know about pfas there
are many thousands of different
compounds it is historically released in
large quantities pfas chemicals are very
mobile through water Pathways pfas is
highly persistent in the environment
he fast degrades into more toxic forms
pfas bioaccumulates in plants and
animals but there is so much more that
we don't know
there are over 6 000 pfas chemicals
towns that have had Water Supplies
contaminated by pfas may not have the
testing of it available to identify all
of what is in the water
yes but we are getting there
I would like to see no statute of
limitations for injuries resulting for
forever chemicals in our bodies as the
result of industrial pollution but this
bill has my support nonetheless because
we need more time than what is being
offered right now
this bill allows science to catch up to
the situation it buys us the necessary
time so that damage can be properly
assessed and polluters can be held
accountable for their actions and the
impact of those actions on our lives
thank you
are there questions for uh former
representative Thomas
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
Diane Potter
[Music]
good morning good morning hi there I
want to thank the panel for allowing me
to give advice
the house and the snow inside and I
couldn't take him out
[Music]
hello Miss Cotter yes good morning can
you folks hear me okay
I think we were getting some background
noise in your call
um is it any better now
[Music]
we're getting a little bit of echo but I
think we can hear you if you want to
testify yes sir I'd like to testify if
you can't hear me well I can redial back
in shall I try down
uh yeah I think that probably is a good
idea one moment thank you
thank you
and in the meantime we'll call upon
Maureen representative Mooney to testify
good morning just to start off can
everybody hear me okay
we can hear you
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman and thank you members of the
committee for the record my name is
Maureen Mooney I'm a state
representative from the town of
Merrimack in Hillsborough County
District number 21.
I'm a co-sponsor of House Bill 236 and
that creating a statute of limitations
on civil actions relative to pfas
I want to express my wholehearted
support for this bill
to give you some background on my
involvement with this bill the late
speaker dick hinch ask that I work with
the Merrimack citizens for clean water
on two legislative issues
as a result I am a co-sponsor of House
Bill 236 as this was one of his two
initiatives we were working on uh prior
to his unexpected passing
of Merrimack is victim to possibly the
worst case of environmental pollution in
the state's history with the discovery
of pfas contaminants in the drinking
water
the town has spent years reacting to
this news and determining the effects
long-term and short term on clean air
drinking water groundwater waste water
and soil
this statute of limitations bill is a
much needed measure to ensure a
guideline for Resident reaction to the
effects of pfas
in 2005
I co-sponsored Senate Bill 75
which created the new section in law
extending the statute of limitations in
civil actions based upon a sexual
assault case
an extended statute of limitations is
critical for those suffering injury and
find themselves balancing their health
and well-being along with the
complications of legal recourse
six years after the date of discovery is
sufficient and the bill is written well
to clearly provide Direction
the citizens of Merrimack ask for its
Passage
and so with that I'll conclude my
remarks and ask that you vote ought to
pass on House Bill
236. thank you
thank you are there any questions for
representative money
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and I see Diane Cotter appears to be
back perhaps we could hear from her next
good morning
better very good thank you you sound
much better
thank you and thank you for the
opportunity to testify before you today
in support of House Bill 236 I'm an
advocate for firefighters who are
exposed to pfas through their equipment
and their a triple F in their turnout
gear
my statement I'll read to you if you
don't mind please it it does have some
tongue twisters in there that that I
stumble on
May our 20 years in what we call the
greatest deception ever at the hands of
our cancer Summit sponsors and voting
members of our safety standards
institution the National Fire Protection
Association
serve as a cautionary tale for anyone
wishing and hoping that corporations
will do the right thing for their
impacted communities
the past weeks I've had the opportunity
to speak with Congressional members from
Massachusetts and New Hampshire to share
the issue of pfas within the fire
service many of these discussions took
place with the efforts of The Honorable
Wendy Thomas and Scott Faber a senior
vice president of governmental Affairs
for the environmental working group
firefighting turnout gear is a complex
technical equipment that must meet the
NFPA standards and codes for structural
firefighting
NFPA committee 1971 has 16 voting
members made up of firefighters
manufacturers special experts
International Association of
firefighters and NFPA members
every purchase order written in the
United States and beyond for turnout
gear in hrf will require that it meet or
exceed NFPA standards and herein lies
the problem Dupont Gore Honeywell are
all voting members of these committees
our turnout gear is made up of three
layers the outer shell is the material
that the public sees it is the most
highly fluorinated textile ever seen by
science Dr Graham Peasley conducted our
own independent study done on turnout
gear the study was orchestrated by
myself the wife of a firefighter with
cancer and a group of firefighters from
Salem Massachusetts Northern California
and Chicago we had no help from
institutions we had no prior skills this
was the first in the world study of
chemicals used on the protective
material of the gear the safety
institution and FPA had 20 years to do
this study they never did they and our
labor force the International
Association of firefighters only sought
and supported studies on the products of
combustion or toxic smoke which was fed
to them by the chemical industry itself
they willingly went along while Dupont
Honeywell Gore knew of the health
effects of pfoa and Teflon they remained
silent while voting on the materials to
be used for the gear not miss Potter I
don't want to cut you short but I I
didn't indicate to everybody that they
limit them to five minutes and
and the issue here is whether or not to
extend the statute of limits and statute
of limitations so
if you you only have a couple of minutes
left if you want to just address that
issue that might be helpful oh yes okay
I'll cut I'll cut right to um
right to our
very relative to Merrimack because
Merrimack as we know makes
cbrn material
and this is why we're so adamant that
this bill be sponsored and supported
um because the chemicals used in turnout
gear uh being used to make the cbrn
material that is being made in Merrimac
um what we'd like to actually indicate
to you today is that we want our
legislators to hold the line for the for
the firefighters who've trusted that
this in our institutions and
specifically that we ask for the passage
of House Bill 236 to hold open the door
for those like us who had to find our
own scientists to discover how long
they've been lied to by omission
thank you
and we're from Rindge New Hampshire
okay
thank you are there questions for Ms
Carter
I seen on thank you for your testimony
today Miss Connor thank you
all right the next person
who signed up to testify is Emma Paradis
or parody
if she's available
if you are available please raise your
hands parody
the next person that signed up is
Laureen Allen
no
good morning
yes my name is I'm a little more
prepared to speak here my name is uh
Laureen Allen I am a resident of
Merrimack I'm also a co-founder of a
citizen group called neuromax citizens
for clean water uh I'd like to ask for
your support this morning for HB 236 I
will not speak long because I think that
the points made by previous
testifiers are superb excellent and I
agree with all of them
um I think what you heard this morning
in the earlier bill was just a little
sense of how laborious and how lengthy
the process is for impacted communities
I think that point has been made also I
think you heard in some of the earlier
testimony on this bill that these
chemicals forever persist they
bioaccumulate in our body they affect
every organ I have actually read
hundreds and hundreds of health studies
from around the world one of them that
really sticks with me is there was study
out of Denmark and it was autopsy
studies and it was absolutely
astonishing because what they found I
have no idea how you do an autopsy study
by the way but what they found is pfas
chemicals including many many short
chain replacement ones that we know are
in the mix here in our community in
every organ of the body the brain the
liver you know the heart everything you
could think of had it and they
delineated by by pop out so what we know
about these compounds is they are toxic
the federal government is years if not
decades behind and it really is up to
the states to try to give some rights to
people so the statute of limitations is
very important especially this concept
of when you realize there's harm in the
area of children in particular I hear
every week from parents in this
community who are looking for physician
guidance and we can't go back you know
we can't make this right what's done is
done but they're realizing that there
are Health disruptions uh to their
children's lives mothers are born with
you know placenta transfer and mothers
who are breastfeeding are very unaware
that they will decrease their body
burden significantly by excreting pfas
chemicals that's in their blood serum to
their infants in breast milk Hoosick
Falls just came out with a report this
week that was appalling there was a
mother there so this speaks to this
issue of when do you learn of of harm
who has a two-year-old who's had many
many issues with his teeth in some
developmental Milestones so teeth
cracking and teeth having issues at two
when the teeth are new they said what
could this be about well pfas impacts
your bones and your bone health is
definitely one of the target points so
this little boy actually was able to
have his blood drawn the mother's levels
from 2016 were significantly lower who6
stopped all their exposure to pfas and
drinking water with full filtration in
the beginning of 2016. she did not have
exposure throughout her pregnancy he's
two years old his blood levels were 22
000 parts per trillion for pfoa alone
that is astonishing here in Southern New
Hampshire we do not have uh the capacity
in New Hampshire to do full
biomonitoring and blood test
um that we should have but we do know
that there are health issues that will
occur so this statute of limitations is
very important I think the sponsors were
being very sensible when they realized
that three years has been the standard
so let's you know not push it too much
let's extend it to six and give more
time uh there was a discussion that the
Merrimack Town Council had last Thursday
night when representative Mooney uh gave
a legislative update and she presented
the gist of this bill until questions or
town counselors who were very very
formed and very conservative and very
sensible made an interesting point they
said why does this bill set a limit at
all of six years they should be no limit
because this goes on and on and on so I
will just leave you with that point from
Our Town Council and in my opinion it's
a great Bill and of course it doesn't go
far enough but we have to be sensible
thank you
okay
thank you for your testimony uh are
there any questions from Ms Alan
seeing none thank you thank you again
for your testimony
are there other people who would like to
speak today if there are in your in
attendance please raise your hand yes
David Greer
hi thank you for letting me speak uh
once again I missed the deadline to uh
sign up to speak but again appreciate
the opportunity my name is David Creer I
am director of public policy at the
business and industry Association uh we
oppose this bill
um and I'll make it pretty simple and
short uh it's just unnecessary I think
there's some confusion about how
statutes of limitations work uh under
current law I think this came up with
representative McLean under current law
your statute of limitations is three
years
um it's generally from when the harm
occurs but in cases of latent defects or
latent harm that clock doesn't begin to
tick until you discover the injury so
for instance in the issue of pfas and
this happens a lot with like medical
malpractice things
um once you discover that you're injured
so you start getting ill and you find
out oh this was because of pfas exposure
that's when the three year starts to
begin it's not when you were exposed to
the pfas it's when that injury actually
occurs and you discover that link to
pfast so three years is ample time to
start your investigation to discover uh
if you should file suit you know this
works pretty well in most other areas
that's why it is the standard three
years
and that would apply here so the
additional six years would just
um really have uh no extra benefits but
it would require businesses to store
records and things even longer than they
normally would giving them extra burdens
and fear of uh increased litigation
um like I said you know the statute of
limitations as it works with three years
is plenty of time to bring lawsuits you
don't even need to have all of the
information before you file suit you are
allowed some extra time during the suit
during the discovery process
um and so there there is plenty of time
to file a suit once you have discovered
that harm exists with that I'm happy to
take any questions
hey representative silver
yes oh thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr crew for taking my question uh
are you aware of what the statute of
limitations in New Hampshire for actions
under the Uniform Commercial Code might
be
uh unfortunately not specifically to the
universe Universal Commercial Code it's
actually the I'm sorry UCC has a general
statute of limitations of four years for
commercial transactions so four years is
actually a year beyond what RSA 508
colon 4 on personal action stats
well thank you I I wasn't aware of that
um but I think you know this bill is
more closely to related to 5084 which
deals with personal injury
um which is where you know most other
um personal injury suits would fall
including medical malpractice thank you
representative Horrigan uh yes thank you
very much Mr chair thank you very much
Mr career and I appreciate the hard work
the Bai Bai does even if I don't
necessarily agree with you on every
issue but
my question is um
this cause of action basically this is
about
um
giving those who are injured by pfas
contamination more time to uh
get the people who did it uh rectified
so I'm wondering like uh yes these are
mostly business these are all businesses
mostly large businesses discharging the
pfas and the water supply but isn't that
um
bad not just for
the households which use the water
supply but also the businesses which
works the water supply so I'm wondering
like um how
oh you think we should balance out the
interest of the businesses who are
harmed by the pollution
um versus those of the businesses which
caused the pollution
all right thank you for the question
um yeah absolutely businesses that would
be harmed by this um also should have
their uh ability to
um you know make make themselves whole
just like um you know a resident or
anyone else but the current statute of
limitations three years is still ample
time to do that because again it that
statute of limitations wouldn't start to
run until that harm is discovered which
then gives them three years to do enough
investigative work to uh figure out how
to file that lawsuit and get that
process going
oh okay thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much Mr career
thank you are there any other questions
for Mr career
thank you for your testimony today
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on this bill
I see no other hands up that being the
case I will close the hearing on House
Bill 236.
and the committee will recess until our
next hearing at 11 o'clock
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back everyone
again we'll reconvene our hearing on the
house Judiciary Committee
the next bill we're scheduled to hear
this morning is House Bill 360 egg
relative to claims for medical
monitoring
I'd note that
prior to the hearing
109 people signed up and supported this
and free sign up in opposition
and only to testify today although I
note that the primary sponsor
representative Cushing uh is in
attendance and wishes to speak today
so to begin our hearing I'll call upon
representative Cushing to give his
testimony
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
I think
I have to turn
I don't mean to be rude um membership
committee for the record I'm
representative Renee Cushing from
Rockingham district 21 in Hampton and
I'm here in support of house bill 368.
is relative to claims to Medical
monitoring this bill should be somewhat
familiar to this committee since it was
before the committee the past two years
as House Bill 661 which
um I will just applaud the committee for
all of the work that it did to uh craft
the language that appears before you
I can think of no other I'm tempted just
to read the uh the ought to pass with
Amendment majority report from
representative Mark McLean of last year
um which I think explains
what this bill sets out to do uh it
provides a private right of action for
toxic exposure and while this is an area
of law that currently requires review
um the committee thought that it would
be important to narrow this to provide a
right of action to seek medical
monitoring for someone who's been
damaged by exposure to toxic chemicals
it uh it makes it easier if you will to
people who have been exposed to toxic
substances to get monitoring for their
health before the onset of any disease
becomes manifest in a way to it would
provide the opportunity to do
appropriate intervention
um and I just would urge the committee
to pass the bill
are there questions for representative
Cushing
yes representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair and thank you um
leader Cushing for taking my question
um is this an exact carbon copy of what
the committee passed thought to pass
Amendment last year
it is except for the effective date okay
it is the it is this is the language
that the you know the house Judiciary
Committee passed 16-3
okay thank you and it was you know
okay
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and and thank you for
taking my question I mean obviously I
have a lot of sympathy for this bill
um but in in the last session we took
this bill to uh the five yard line and
um the governor vetoed it and that veto
was upheld so are there any new develops
or any new developments or anything that
you could share with the committee
um that you think might lead to a
different outcome this time around
I just think that there's a growing
Consciousness and awareness of the
damage that is being done to the
citizens of the state by uh entities
that uh that knowingly
um provide knowingly expose uh citizens
to toxic chemicals I think we're we're
not seeing a decline in cancer rates
we're not seeing a decline in health
impacts from chemical exposure if
anything I think the passage of time
makes this even more urgent
foreign Corrigan
um yes well my question is similar to uh
previous ones so the Billet hb661 per se
was tabled by the Senate I was checking
the docket but it was uh
unless it was in one of the Omnibus
bills and I'm embarrassed to say I don't
remember exactly which one so um
so do you want to comment more in the
legislation
on the bus bill here thank you
representative Corrigan that's my
recollection too I know I I get the
numbers mixed up as we moved to the
pandemic and there were bills that uh
we're taken and included in other bills
uh that having been said I I think
what's important to remember is how hard
this Judiciary Committee worked on this
particular piece of legislation I mean
you invited in stakeholders it was not
done yet I just I I don't know how many
subcommittees I don't know how many
wordsmithing sessions there were
um at the end I think what the what he
came up with is a really good and
important piece of legislation and I I
would I would urge you to pass it again
oh thank you yeah thank you Mr leader
thank you very much Mr chair yes I I I
agree and um of course the fact is
vetoed that means the Senate supported
it too it's just a governor uh the
governor objectives of something in the
Omnibus Bill so
um thanks
that was then this was now of course so
like
let's hope for a different outcome of
this time at 2021. I would not
necessarily preclude you know the
someone re-examining a legislation in a
different session and seeing it in a
different light of new information
recognizing a new urgency perhaps
thank you uh are there any other
questions for
leader cushion
saying none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you committee
other persons who indicated their desire
to testify
a Chris Appel is Chris Appel with us
yes hello yes we can hear you oh great
sorry this is new to me too the virtual
testifying
um well thank you Mr chairman I can't
tell if you can see me or not
um
but I first of all just wanted to thank
you for uh you and the committee for the
privilege of allowing me to testify
today even virtually uh again my name is
Chris Apel I'm an attorney at the law
firm of shoecardian bacon in Washington
D.C and I'm testifying on behalf of the
American Court reform Association in
opposition to HB 368. and my goal here
is to provide more of a national
perspective on medical monitoring and to
discuss some of the specific concerns
with this bill
I also submitted written testimony
detailing some of these concerns and I
thought I would just Begin by
re-emphasizing what medical monitoring
entails
it allows a claimant to recover damages
where he or she has no present injury
and will likely never develop an injury
and that basic idea is a fairly radical
Concept in tort law the existence of an
actual injury has traditionally been the
linchpin for tort liability
and one of the basic problems with
allowing the unimpaired to recover
damages is that it depletes the pool of
resources available for those who have
actually suffered a serious injury and
this isn't just hypothetical asset
depletion either the history of asbestos
litigation in America provides a helpful
example
there are a few courts around the
country allowed tens of thousands of
unimpaired claimants to recover based on
their mere exposure to Asbestos and the
result in my view is fairly predictable
unimpaired claimants flocked to these
jurisdictions draining the available
assets for individuals who developed
mesothelioma and other cancers
manufacturers were forced into
bankruptcy leading to the creation of
asbestos trusts many of which now only
pay pennies on the dollar to the
seriously impaired and this type of
concern led the U.S Supreme Court to
reject medical monitoring albeit under a
federal statute and most State high
courts that have considered medical
monitoring in the past 20 years have
expressly rejected it including for
example the Illinois Supreme Court just
last year
and HP 368 would not only adopt a new
cause of action for medical monitoring
which I can explain as a minority
approach among the minority of states
that do allow medical monitoring but the
legislation would do so in an extremely
broad manner based on other
considerations
and here I thought it would be helpful
to just go through some of the bills uh
provisions of course the bill states
that any chemical or biological
substance that can be shown to be
hazardous or toxic can give rise to a
lawsuit
the bill therefore would apply to
exposure to countless substances
regardless of whether a substance is
recognized under state or federal law as
hazardous basically an attorney just
needs to find an expert willing to opine
that something is hazardous which is not
really a tall order
a plaintiff only needs to show a
significant exposure created an
increased risk of illness there's no
threshold for how significant or
insignificant that increased risk must
be
the bill also expressly says that a
person does not need to prove that
illness is certain or likely to develop
as a result of the exposure the only
real Safeguard here is whether a doctor
would agree that diagnostic testing is
reasonably necessary
and this is a bit of editorializing
immediately but in my experience many
doctors believe the practice of
defensive medicine is a very real thing
so some doctors may be inclined okay
testing based on marginal exposures
which creates a potential for abuse
especially if they're say like pressed
by an attorney to to authorize medical
monitoring
the bill also says that a claimant's
present or past health status shall not
be at issue in a claim for medical
monitoring so if a person has a
pre-existing condition for example a
genetic predisposition to something like
breast cancer that information would
appear to be unavailable for use by a
defendant in a medical monitoring case
in other words a defendant could not
argue that a plaintiff's increased risk
of disease was due to factors such as
genetics and not an alleged exposure and
I would submit that stripping away such
basic defenses would allow liability to
be imposed in a fundamentally unfair
manner
the bill also expressly authorizes
Awards of attorney fees and would give
courts the option of awarding Damages
for meta for monitoring as a lump sum
instead of requiring that funds be
placed in a court supervised program
administered by medical professionals
and this combination could be a recipe
for Mischief because it provides an
incentive for attorneys to actively seek
out litigation and recover medical
monitoring damages on behalf of a group
or a class without any requirement that
any of the unimpaired claimants actually
use the funds for monitoring purposes so
there doesn't appear to be anything in
the bill prohibiting a successful
claimant who receives a lump sum damage
award uh for their future monitoring
from saying going out and buying a TV
finally the Bill's three-year statute of
limitations appears to adopt a purely
subjective standard as opposed to an
objective standard which is antithetical
to the purpose of a statute of
limitations to establish a definite
period after which Claims can no longer
be brought
the limitations period appears to be
triggered only by a claimant's actual
discovery of his or her exposure not
when the claimant reasonably should have
discovered the exposure
the bill provision stating that the date
when the hazardous substance was
released is immaterial further suggests
a purely subjective limitations period
in which claims may be brought based on
alleged exposures occurring many years
or decades in the past and so the end
result is a bill that would subject
businesses and other entities to
potentially massive new liability
exposure overnight at a time when many
are still struggling to keep the lights
on during the pandemic and for these
reasons all of these reasons I
respectfully urge this committee to
reject this bill and I'd be pleased to
answer any questions
there are some questions representative
Smith
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
you um Mr Appel for your testimony I
noticed that um you represent 60 of the
U.S property Casualty Insurance Market
can you tell me what percent of the New
Hampshire uh property Casualty Insurance
Market you represent uh sorry I don't
represent the insurance Market I
represent the American tort reform
Association
which is a broad-based group of
businesses concerned about abuse in the
Civil Justice System
I I'm sorry I guess I misread the
testimony that came in I I really do um
apologize for that
I see this testimony is from
um apcia I thought it was uh your
testimony I apologize no no worries
I guess if I could just follow up on
either members of your Association who
are new hampshire-based companies
uh I believe so I I mean it's a big
organization so I would I would I don't
want to say a hundred percent but I
would I would be very surprised I don't
know the exact membership list of
everyone in atra so
um
thank you
represent representative page
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Pell for um taking my question I'm I'm
reading your written testimony
um and I noticed that you've cited and
in your testimony here today you've
cited state courts that you suggest have
rejected
um similar bills I I noticed there was a
quote from a Supreme Court case that
didn't have a citation
in the letter and I'm not sure I see a
citation to any State Court decisions
um am I missing something
um well my testimony does refer to only
one Court decision which is the U.S
Supreme Courts and it it you're right I
didn't include the site to Metro north
um first Buckley but that's the that's
the U.S Supreme Court it just took out a
few uh sentence uh statements by the
court of just expressing concern about
the flood and unpredictable liability
which is
a theme throughout all the courts
rejecting medical monitoring I mean this
is again this is the majority of courts
in the country
um medical monitoring is a minority
position and as I alluded to in my
testimony the this approach of adopting
a cause of action a separate cause of
action is a minority approach even among
the minority of states that adopt
medical monitoring only five states in
America adopt a cause of action a
private cause of action for medical
monitoring the other states actually
that have allowed medical monitoring
have done so as an element of Damages
for an existing torque claim
Mr chairman can I have a follow-up
question you certainly may uh Mr Pell so
could you provide the committee with
those I believe in you your oral
testimony you mentioned a court in
Illinois and other courts so I'm
wondering if you could provide citations
to the to the committee or I don't I
don't see them
uh yeah I mean do you want a citation
for every
State that's rejected medical monitoring
I guess which whatever you had cited in
your in your testimony here today
um oh okay I mean I I can give a I can
provide a list of citations I mean
there's a lot of courts that have done
thank you Mr
thank you representative Horrigan oh
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much Mr Rappel um
uh well one thing that struck me strange
was you you complained about the
possibility of plaintiff's buying TV
sets with your clients money and TV sets
are actually
uh thanks to technology so if you've
been to Best Buy in the last 10 years
you'll find they're much cheaper than
they used to be but that's and of course
some some of this does apply to class
action suits which often pay off
relatively small amounts of money but my
main question is um just wanted to
clarify you're not saying that medical
monitoring is bad per se just that your
your argument's about who should pay for
when it's necessary is that the is that
a correct summary of your position or if
not maybe you can straighten me out well
my my position would be that medical
monitoring I mean the tort system has
existed for Centuries with a fundamental
principle that an injury is required for
a tort recovery it's been it's really
what's guided tort law it's been like
the rudder in tort law this bill
reverses that and to be clear other as I
mentioned a few other states have have
gone that route
um but I I it's a public policy choice
and I would argue that the public policy
favors
retaining assets for those who actually
develop a serious injury so you're not
depleting the pool of resources for when
they develop a very serious illness and
because that's what I mean that's the
history of asbestos litigation in
America has taught us that lesson that
you what happens when you open the
doorway to unimpaired claimants is that
the resources get drained from
like the asbestos defendants for forcing
many of them 120 of them into bankruptcy
um and then what you have as a result
and this took years this took a decade
or two to actually occur but what you
happen at the end of the day is you have
people that now have developed a serious
illness and are dying who don't get a
full recovery because of this
follow up yes you may follow up well
first of all I guess maybe I should
admit I mean I think I could still vote
on this bill objectively but my uh late
father who died uh 10 years ago some of
the members of the committee uh
probably knew him um he he was one of
the I think it's hundreds of thousands
or even millions of victims of the uh of
the asbestos because he served in the uh
served in the Navy in the 1950s when
there's asbestos on everything so that's
just sort of uh
uh my I have a family member who had
lost he was one of the victims of that
and we
we got a small amount of money of it but
uh
but also my question is going through
the monitoring is doesn't that help
prevent uh a minor problem one that
hasn't manifested itself from becoming
something
like what killed my father which was
mesothelioma so when
would it be good would it better I mean
put inside the question who pays for it
but isn't it still a good thing to have
medical monitoring so that uh small
problems don't develop into fatal ones
well I mean when you look at when you
look at it like that again it's a
balancing of interests it's whether or
not it's worth it to pay for monitoring
up front and I should point out that if
someone gets an illness they can recover
all the monitoring that they've as part
of their injuries all the monitoring
they've incurred to that point when
they're when they actually have a
physical injury but the idea that you're
paying for a lot most people who won't
even ever develop an injury and you're
just giving them funds I would argue
that the public policy does not favor
that and that you're actually you're
going to end up doing a disservice to
those who die of a Syria or who contract
a very serious illness later on because
the resources might not be available for
them
no I mean yeah in all fairness in my
case follow-up well
not to get in debate I can save some of
these excessive but of course in life
our situation and uh it's probably true
for almost all the families uh
the money is not much of a consolation
for what happened you know like we're
our you know we are amazing is this a
question
well
um do you find that the money makes much
difference to the uh families who are
damaged um you know since
the tort system is compensating someone
for a death of a loved one is never
going to be enough I mean there's no
amount that can replace that the tort
system tries to do the best it can to
right or wrong and that's what it and
that's the goal and
yes
but millions of dollars for some people
they value it differently some people
they would find it to be an adequate
recovery some people would say it's
never enough so the tort system kind of
splits the difference there and and does
the the best it can but when you have
unimpaired claimants recovering for an
entry they might never develop that
really puts a huge strain on the system
and when you have a bill that's
expansive as this one you really put all
businesses uh Under Pressure I mean I
earned her uh enormous strain and again
as I mentioned it's a this is a trying
time for the American economy in general
um and so putting an extra strain right
now I I would just argue is the public
policy doesn't support that but again
it's it it is a it's a topic where
reasonable Minds have different so I
won't pretend that it's not
thank you representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and if you'll indulge
me I just have a couple of quick
questions and thank you Mr Appel for
taking my questions my first question is
in the case uh of the asbestos asbestos
um litigation that you cite where 120
companies were put out of business was
was there a negligence component to
those 120 people uh or companies being
put out of business or was it a strict
liability
um or was there a negligence component
in that case
um I mean I can't speak to all the cases
obviously but I would I would imagine
there's there's strict liability claims
and negligence claims included in many
of them okay so and just a quick
follow-up subsequent to the Metro North
decision there have been
um many times in state courts
um where there has been negligence that
the the case has been successful
um you know Bauer versus Westinghouse
and uh Donovan versus Philip Morris and
and I think those have not had any
issues but you did mention an Illinois
case
um just last year where the court
overturned it
um now was was there a negligent
component to that or can you share any
of the details of that case with us uh
yeah uh so there was uh I believe there
was a negligent component to it it was
uh I actually have a
it was a with um lead exposure in
alleged lead poisoning in the city water
lines uh in Illinois so uh the city of
Chicago sued
um on behalf of City residents to
replace the water mains essentially and
wanted medical monitoring for
I I mean a broad group maybe the whole
city of Chicago or whatever affected
area that was in Chicago
um
and then uh the court rejected it and
among other things the court said uh
that uh the court reaffirmed the present
injury require physical present physical
injury requirements that it establishes
a workable standard for judges and
juries who must determine liability
protects court dockets from becoming
clogged with comparatively unimportant
or trivial claims and reduces the threat
of unlimited and unpredictable liability
um so they the court said there are very
practical reasons for requiring a
showing of actual or realized harm
before permitting recovery and tort that
was the that in the case is City of
Chicago versus Barry
um which is September of last year
and I can include that uh I know I
said I was going to put the some sites
to at least the state High courts and
you mentioned Bauer in West Virginia and
Donovan in Massachusetts
um
though I mean power is probably it will
probably the most criticized medical
monitoring case in American history but
um those are some of the broad uh Bauer
in particular is probably the broadest
of of medical monitoring and in the case
of asbestos
the the state legislature adopted
specific asbestos reforms later because
of the uh the abusive nature of it
um there's I believe West Virginia and
of the five states that allow a cause of
action for medical monitoring uh I know
West Virginia and Florida have both
adopted medical asbestos medical
criteria laws which effectively require
a present showing of a present injury
before they can proceed in the tort
system
okay thank you are there any other
questions for Mr Appel
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you for having me
thank you
um I got a text and it said there that
perhaps I did not recognize uh
representative D Lorenzo with the last
speaker would representative Cushing for
her question and do you still have a
question for representative Cushing if
he's available
I almost said Mr chairman thank you okay
I apologize if I if I missed you sorry
and
the next speaker is uh when uh Wendy
Thomas
if she's available
yes yes I am thank you thank you for uh
inviting me to this well thank you for
having me at this committee uh Mr chair
esteemed colleagues of the Judiciary
Committee I am former representative
Wendy Thomas for Merrimack and I come
before you in support of House Bill 368
a bill that will allow a claim for
medical monitoring to be made if a
specific if specific conditions are met
if a party has been found to cause
exposure to a designated hazardous or
toxic substance which increases risk of
illness or disease
I live in Merrimack we have a private
well that in 2016 tested so high with
pfas chemicals that we had to stop using
our water
we have been on bottled water for the
last five years every month we get 164
gallons of water delivered to our house
and that's what we use for drinking
cooking and water for our pets
five years later our well was recently
tested in this past January and our well
is still testing at three times the
level of allowable contamination
our well has been contaminated that we
know about for half a decade
and yet I and my six children have never
been evaluated for pfas contamination in
our bodies we have never had a blood
test to see if these chemicals exist
inside of us
pfas chemicals are a hormone disrupter
my daughters may have fertility issues
if we knew how much pfas is in their
bodies we could be on the lookout for
fertility issues and breast cancer
pfas chemicals can cause learning
disabilities
if we know a child with a learning
disability has pfas in their system
perhaps we could offer them different
services or a different approach to
teaching
pfas causes kidney damage as a woman who
has nursed all six of her children and
ended and ended up drinking a lot of our
wells contaminated water I may end up
with kidney disease if I know the extent
of the chemicals in my body my doctor
might request increased kidney testing
and more significantly pfas is an
emerging contaminant which means that we
are still learning about it
tancobain considers it important enough
to test our well water but we have no
way of testing our bodies
this is particularly critical now
because there are new reports that
populations contaminated contaminated
with pfas seem to have more
susceptibility to the covid virus and
alarmingly pfas in the blood seems to
interfere with the efficacy of the covid
vaccine
communities that are hard hit by pfest
may need to have additional vaccines or
regular boosters in order for them to
remain healthy
we need this information gathered from
medical monitoring to make our health
decisions
no one should get sick simply because of
where they live
medical monitoring gives us control over
our own health
the bottom line is that we did not put
these chemicals into our bodies we have
them because we ingested chemicals from
from industrial contaminated water
if we have a right to see how much of
these chemicals are in our water surely
we have a right to know how much of
these chemicals are in our bodies
this bill which provides medical
monitoring for pfas is an important step
to protect the rights and health of New
Hampshire residents affected by pfas
contamination from industrial pollution
I urge you to vote OTP thank you
thank you
yes representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question honorable Thomas
um
I you say that
testing is not available to find out how
much pfas is in your body I I assume
there is a test that would see how much
is in your blood do you know what the
cost would be for such a test
I don't have that information I think
the last time that people talked about
this it was around 400
.
um but
I am not going to say that that's that's
the price because I don't have it in
front of me
um
but what one of the issues is that a lot
of Physicians don't even know what test
to order and that's that's the bigger
issue
um they you know if you go many
Physicians don't don't know anything
about pfas and this is something we keep
bumping up to bumping up against in in
Merrimack you know our residents go to
doctors and they talk about uh pfas
contamination and the doctors simply
don't know what to order or how to to
monitor the conditions and potential
conditions follow-up Miss chairman yep
go ahead so
you're asking for medical monitoring but
you're you're also saying that doctors
don't know what to look for I'm I'm
confused by that can you help clarify
um well Matt I'm assuming that medical
monitoring would be a standardized
approach to testing blood and and body
tissue for pfat contamination so so part
of this
um medical monitoring would be educating
the medical community on which tests to
perform
thank you
are there
any other questions for former
representative Thomas
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify today if so please raise your
hand
someone from New Hampshire safe water
has raised their hand
yes hi this is uh former representative
Mindy Mesmer uh of rye and I am grateful
to the committee for hearing this bill
as representative Cushing stated this is
HB 368 is a submittal of HB 661 and a
prior bill that was submitted in 2017
that looks to
have medical monitoring be part of an
award and by a judge and it signals to
signal to the court that the general
court agrees that this is necessary
and I would like to say you know this is
an important issue for many communities
in the state of New Hampshire not just
with respect to pfas which is something
you've heard about prior to this to my
testimony but also with respect to
people that are suffering from exposure
to gasoline mtbe which is a big issue
which we all know about here in the
state of New Hampshire but it's also a
question of whether or not the people
should have the ability to know how
their health can be monitored when
they've been unknowingly exposed to
chemicals that could impact their health
and what those long-term impacts may be
and to avoid the burden on our Health
Care system for these Health impacts
that may get out of control without
earlier interventions
as uh you may have heard there was a big
study done with respect to pfas these
teflon-like chemicals that have impacted
a lot of the State of New Hampshire
called the C8 science panel study which
was done in 70 000 people which showed
probable connections between six
different outcomes kidney and testicular
cancer ulcerative colitis thyroid
disease high cholesterol and
pregnancy-induced hypertension in fact
the latter of which concerningly causes
low birth weight it's been tied to
limited nutrient and oxygen supply to
unborn babies and results in other
complications through birth many of
these things if monitored early on or if
we know about them could improve
outcomes and reduce the cost burden on
the Health Care system
I am intimately familiar uh being from
the Seacoast area uh related to the peas
exposure where the peas Air Force Base
the former Air Force uh the use of pfas
containing chemicals has impacted
severely the drinking water system on
the Seacoast where 3 000 people
including 250 children were proven to
have been exposed to pfas and now have
elevated levels of pfas in their serum
and unknown health effects for the
future for these children and families
and one of the things I was mentioned
prior is we are now starting to
understand that people exposed to pfas
with high burdens of pfas in their
bodies or elevated levels could
experience more severe impacts from
covid-19 if they are if they can
contract it there's also now emerging
information about the efficacy of
vaccines not just the coveted vaccine
but many childhood vaccines and the uh
exposure to these chemicals in
children's bodies and particularly one
of the pfas chemicals with respect to
the efficacy of the covid-19 vaccine has
just emerged so this is a very real
issue I want to turn your attention also
to the town of Merrimack where in
response to my bill in 2017 they had to
put in for an air permit saint-gobain
performs Plastics they as part of that
permit they were required to install a
thermal oxidation unit on their
emissions to control the contamination
that they've caused across the southern
portion of the state unfortunately that
deadline to install that passed on
February 10th and the town of Merrimack
has indicated in our HB 737 statutory
commission that they are looking at
within days filing suit against
cincobain to stop the collusion of our
communities in New Hampshire
that's great but the people of Merrimack
deserve to know the impacts that this is
and has caused to their health there's
only been a random sample of about 218
residents in the Merrimack area who have
been able to get their blood tested for
pfac pfas exposure and what we did learn
from that small sample of random people
is that the people of Merrimack have
twice the national average of pfas in
their blood
and a paper which has now been accepted
for a National Conference will detail
how the people of Merrimack are subject
to increased risk of adult developing
colon cancer laryngitis laryngeal cancer
kidney and renal cancer brain and
Central Nervous cancer and Leukemia and
when compared to national averages the
residents of Merrimack are statistically
significantly
at risk for mesothelioma as a esophageal
cancer bladder cancer and thyroid
cancers this will all be presented at a
National Conference in in April uh so
this bill is really about uh as uh
representative McLean pointed out uh
proving that there is uh online a under
um 125 t31a that the defendant has
negligently caused exposure and that the
plaintiff now suffers an increased risk
of illness or disease and as I've
outlined there are several of these
diseases associated with exposure just
to pfast that if detected early on could
save the Health Care System a
significant cost and also perhaps change
the um the outcome of the health of
these people in the future as someone
who has been
directly impacted now not only by the
kova 19 issue in our communities but
also have a family member that has
suffered is suffering from an
environmentally triggered cancer I find
this to be an extremely
important bill and I asked the committee
to seriously consider passing it once
again and ask for your support thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony
yes representative Macbeth
thank you Mr chair and thank you
um The Honorable uh Master for taking my
question
um I'm wondering we'd had some testimony
earlier about the high cost of testing
uh broad spectrum of New Hampshire
citizens prior to them being identified
as having high levels of pfas I'm
wondering if uh you have any data on the
cost of you know early detection and
early treatment outcomes
um so if the medical monitoring is done
um does that cost as both in lost of
life and medical costs does it
compensate for that broad testing cost
thank you
I would thank you for the question
representative mcbeath I I do believe
that you know if things like
hypertension during pregnancy can be
controlled certainly the outcome of that
birth could be affected in a positive
way
um things like thyroid disease and high
cholesterol I can assume that those also
detected early and controlled early on
could result in much better outcomes for
those people but in terms of the cancers
I would have to go back and try to
monetize some of these but um I'm sure
there there is some information
available about early intervention I
mean that's why we do screening for
breast cancer it's better to catch
breast cancer at stage one than at stage
four in terms of the outcome and the
cost associated with treating with that
so I appreciate your question and
absolutely I mean I can I don't have
numbers to tell you about the cost
savings but I can certainly understand
that those costs would be significant
thank you thank you very much good
are there
questions
or former representative misner
thank you for your testimony today thank
you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify today who hasn't had that
opportunity
I don't see any hands up and therefore I
will declare the hearing closed on House
Bill 368.
and unless there's something else we
need to address I will recess at this
point in time indicate that the
Judiciary Committee will oh
representative Chase Do you have a
can't hear you representative Chase for
some reason
she sometimes struggles with the sound
on her computer even when she's unmuted
there you go I don't know what happens
here just quickly
um
Mr chair you had told us there were 109
oppositions did you say how many support
there was
no there was 109 in support three in
opposition today thank you I missed that
thank you
uh Mr guest representative Horrigan well
this is a pretty minor point it doesn't
affect me but um my recollection is and
we called the bowl we skipped over
representative page who would have been
the next to last person on the rotation
aside from yourself so he uh he first is
here
um I'm not sure if he's spoken but he
has been here when I actually checked
rolled back to me in the YouTube video
and he was there right when they started
recording so he's been here all along so
certainly uh he should be checked off as
present if he has not been checked off
already so
thank you thank him for his patience too
so
thank you
I thought he was checked off so
that's probably you're probably correct
thank you
and any other things we need to do
and again I'll recess re recess our
hearing and we'll reconvene at one
o'clock at which time we will go into
executive session
to address our bills
thank you we'll see you all at one
foreign
thank you
with
you
foreign
thank you
people
foreign
thank you
questions
foreign
thank you
good afternoon everybody
a college meeting of the house Judiciary
Court
committee back to order
and
we're here this afternoon and I'm also
going to indicate that the committee
will go into executive session
to address bills which we have already
heard
we have four early bills which need to
be addressed today for sure and then
we'll get through as many other bills as
I think we can do
before we begin I just want to say that
um
this committee has been a pleasure to
work with and up until this point
uh We've
had no reasons to have various dew point
viewpoints or opinions and and to
express them and we've worked together
very well
today probably will be the first time
where people will have different points
of view and different perspectives on
items
and I just uh expect and I know we will
continue to work together cooperatively
and even though we may have differences
of opinions we'll work together
uh well efficiently and cooperatively
and respectfully and I and I know
everybody will
and we'll get our business done today
um
the
we already have voted on four four bills
which I have reported out the committee
reports have been done and forwarded
to the clerk's office
the
and what I'll do is uh try to go through
the bills as we have heard them the
first bill we heard of course was House
Bill 248 which we elected to retain
the next bill was a cacr six
and
that is uh the bill
with regard to extending the age for
judges from 70 to 75
and I guess I'd ask if anyone has a
motion
on that to begin the discussion
Mark did I saw your hand up did you have
a motion
I think Cam Cameron all fairness had his
hand up first okay
my hand up sorry excuse me I'm sorry uh
representative Kenny
thank you so much
um Mr chairman um I move Amendment uh
2021.0291 H4 cacr6
chairman you have to have
um a recommendation before you can move
an amendment you have to have a positive
recommendation right sorry about that
foreign
so
do you want to make a motion with regard
to a specific recommendation
um sure I'll
so to confirm so I would have to make
the motion
OTP in order to move an amendment
I believe that's true okay um then yeah
I'll move OTP
and is that second
Ed by a representative Chase
and would you like to address your
sure so I at this point I wouldn't speak
to the amendment just the original Bill
correct
Mr chair would it not be proper for
representative Penny to move OTP a
I believe that is the proper motion
representative rise and then
because he has to introduce the
amendment and we have to vote on it
before we can bring forward otpa that is
correct
and now he's going to introduce his
Amendment then we will vote on the
amendment and if it passes then he will
move otpa
right well he he's going to introduce
his Amendment now
and so basically representative Kenny
you're moving your amendment is that
correct
uh yes Mr chairman
why don't you and is there a second on
the amendment
representative Chase will second the
amendment as well and do you want to
address your Amendment
uh yes please Mr chairman and thank you
to representative rice and
representative Smith for the guidance
it's been a little bit since I've
introduced an amendment
um so basically it's a pretty simple
um Amendment
that kind of just uh takes out the part
including the governor and the uh
Council
approving the judge to continue at at
the age of 70 and Beyond
um I take that out and I'll I'll raise
three points for you to consider
um first I think that it is possible
um unintended consequences could come uh
with leaving the governor and the
council involved
um I don't think
that you need too strong of an
imagination to see uh where political
pressure could come from uh the
possibility that a judge at the age of
68 69 70
um could feel pressure to uh judge in a
certain manner to stay on a politician's
um good side I just think that it is
very important
to um make sure that there is no
pressure on the judicial branch
um number two I just I don't think that
part of the bill is needed
um at all I I think that we can find
many of examples of Judges who if they
decided to continue after 70
should have had the right to do so no
strings attached
um and if you want to look at examples
of individuals like that you can look at
the prime sponsor the chairman of this
committee individuals who testified
um
and lastly
I I do believe that it makes the bill
um stronger as as a whole so I I would
urge my colleagues to support this
amendment thank you Mr Jim
yes representative McLean
uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
representative Kenny for the amendment
one of the things also stated in the
amendment is that no person shall hold
the office or judge or serve as a judge
of any Court in any case or controversy
after he has attained uh the age of 75
years so what exactly does that language
mean
thank you uh so to my understanding
um it would basically mean that after a
judge hits 75 that
um they would have to follow the same
process that they follow now at the age
of 70. um
okay
representative Macbeth okay
um thank you Mr chair
um I wanted to uh speak to the motion in
in favor of ought to pass
um because I I feel and I think we've
just recently been made aware again of
how our judicial conduct uh committee uh
works very well accepts complaints from
publics at the public and does a good
job of uh supervising and disciplining
um and removing judges that aren't
appropriate for all sorts of reasons so
we don't need a special counsel or
separate group to be looking over judges
for just one particular category thank
you
third discussion
representative McLean
I'm still getting used to the new button
um um I agree with uh representative
Macbeth's comments however there was
also testimony
um that going beyond the age of 70 might
inhibit the bringing of of fresh blood
onto the court and also I don't think
that there was any testimony
um uh
uh that really established a need uh
compelling enough to bring forth a
constitutional amendment we have lots of
judges in the pipeline
um so I really don't see anything in
this
particular casr where there's a need
that would drive uh doing a
constitutional change
president Macbeth
thank you your honor um if I could just
speak to representative McLean's um I I
agree with you that um maybe when you
talk about fresh blood if you're just
looking for young blood uh you might be
correct but this day and age there are a
lot of non-traditional people that are
going to law school later or people that
are coming into New Hampshire later in
their careers and just in general it's
not just attorneys it's everyone that's
kind of changing careers so I think that
there really is a need as people
individuals particularly in New
Hampshire are aging and people are
working longer that you can still get
fresh blood in the Judiciary by raising
the um age of judges and allowing people
in the latter part of their careers or
non-traditional people that come in
later to law or to the bench
um take the plates
um there and you know serve the
constituency thank you
representative Horrigan
representative Horgan I think you have
to unmute
um I think well recruiting the judges I
think it's not as easy as people think
it is so there aren't that many people
it's a very special take a very special
skill set with actually not that many
people necessarily have
um and also
we don't really have much of a pipeline
for them we've uh we Consolidated a lot
of part-time judges into full-time jobs
and also every budget cycle including
this one we've always been limiting the
number of Judges so the number of
Superior and circuit court judges if you
have is less than there might be a
demand for because there's a large
pretty significant backlog in both those
court systems partially because uh
especially because we've limited the
number of number of Judges that the
Judiciary can hire so we don't have
actually that much of a pipeline in the
lower courts those are pretty much
um
those those are pretty much filled up
and of course those courts are also uh
subject to the same 70-year age limit as
the Supreme Court we usually think about
the Supreme Court but this also applies
to the Circuit Court and the Superior
Court judges um
and uh certainly there's lots of people
who are Cape over 70 who are certainly
capable of serving including yourself Mr
chair we have representative Landon
former Justice Convoy all of whom you
know certainly
you can tell they're fully capable of
serving on the state supreme court or
any judge obviously still very Divine
somebody their minds are still very
strong you know they're still like very
engaged so and then the other hand is
probably some people much younger than
70 who can't do
that job anymore so I would I would say
raising it five five years is a
that's a very simple thing which should
have been done uh years ago so
and and really there is and Jessica my
first point they really aren't you know
these a good judge is actually very
scarce scarce commodity so we shouldn't
be taking people out of the Court just
because they've passed the age of 70. so
thanks
add my two cents to it um
at first I I think I agreed it was a
no-brainer but then since then I've
given that quite a bit of thought
and I was impressed by the testimony we
received from representative Piedra uh
as well
a couple of things first of all I'm not
the question is what what what's the
problem that we're trying to solve here
I guess is the question
and
is there a shortage of judges and do we
need to raise the age in order to
accommodate them I don't think there's
any shortage of people who apply for
judgeships in the state and frankly when
you're looking at a job that pays 164
000 a year and probably has the most
lucrative retirement plan of any state
employee
where you retire with 75 of
what you were earning on your last year
working
um
I I don't think there will be any
shortage and in fact judges
I would say that most of the judges who
become judges get paid more as judges
than they were being paid as attorneys
before they became judges in this state
so I don't think there's any shortage
and I don't think we need to do it for
that reason and I got to thinking about
uh the issue of and because everybody
says the same thing about age and that
is well when in the 1790s when this was
created people died at an earlier age
and now people live longer therefore
therefore it makes sense to extend the
age but I don't think the age of 70 was
done based upon life expectancy at the
time I think the age was done based upon
competency
and
and the question was at what age do you
no longer become competent to
and I I don't honestly know if between
1790 and today people who turn 70 are
any more or less competent than they
were back then
the another point I think is
is
why 75
isn't 75 just as arbitrary as 70. why
wouldn't it be 80.
or 85 or why would we put a limit on it
at all
and I guess the other the other the
other consideration I might have is
the idea term limits I believe in term
limits I think we ought to have term
limits for legislators as and and but
the idea that uh you know fresh blood
isn't a bad idea new ideas aren't a bad
idea and the fact is that people do get
stale when they stay in one job for a
long period of time so
my perspective on the bill I think has
changed a bit since because I was
eager to co-sponsor originally
I certainly and along in the short
because I should be addressing the
amendment and and that is
I don't
I don't agree with the amendment I think
if the issue is if the issue really is
an issue of Competency then I think a
determination ought to be made with
regard to competency at the time and I
understand it's a political process but
I got to tell you
if you look at the judges that are
appointed the appointment is a political
process
those are my thoughts
anybody else want to speak to the
amendment
you want to vote on the amendment
okay
um excuse me before we do we still have
a couple folks that need to be on camera
yes if they're going to vote they need
to be on camera
so we're voting on the amendment right
now whether to approve the amendment
which was offered by
representative Kenny
and
I guess I asked the clerk to take the
roles
this is Mr clerk there
[Applause]
and see him is he here looks like we
lost our Clerk
I don't know where our clerk went
well Jen do you have you heard from Kurt
at all
I have not I was just thinking about
trying to give him a call
it looks like representative rice is
getting him on the phone
foreign
Mr chair yes
um while we're waiting for
um the clerk to
um
appear one hopes
um I just want I have a couple of
questions is the way you are going to
proceed you're not going to do the early
Bills first you're just going to go
through in order
yeah well the early bills were two of
the early bills were
we would do quickly
and I thought we probably would end up
with a lot of discussion on the
other two
okay if you would prefer I would be
happy to do the early bills Mr chair I
prefer
for us this to unfold the way you want
it to unfold I just hold on for a second
I'm sorry
yeah
go go ahead representative Smith
um I I just wanted to know to make sure
that
um we we got to the early bills even if
we didn't quite finish all the others so
that's the one thing and then the next
are you proceeding
um with when you call a bill the first
person you call on would make a motion
or to pass or itl or whatever
and uh then they would SEC it would be
seconded and then that person would
explain
why he or she made the motion and then
other people would speak is that how
you're going to go on I think that makes
sense okay good thank you very much for
clarifying that thank you
representative rice
okay hold on
hold on one second
um so the problem is that representative
wolper has lost power at his home
so he is on his phone trying to connect
through the zoom link but because he
doesn't have Internet it's giving him a
hard time
so
then Welker could connect by telephone
only and using that he has to be on
video to be able to vote that's correct
yeah
um did it come back up yet no nothing
[Music]
um
nothing
there's no way you can do video on his
phone
no he's he's trying he's trying to
okay he's trying to connect via his
phone because he has the Zoom app on his
phone but it keeps telling him he's not
connected to the internet Jen do you
have any suggestions should I have him
call he may need to his phone may be
like defaulting to his Wi-Fi so he may
just need to turn on cellular at home
did you hear that turn off your Wi-Fi on
your phone
okay
go under your settings
he might also have to enable cellular
for the Zoom app
okay they go under to the apps where you
enable for cellular you may have to
enable cellular under the Zoom app so if
you scroll down you'll find Zoom click
on that
okay
well it'll it'll be under your settings
though not the app itself it'll be under
your settings
yes
and make sure that you have cellular
data on there
okay we're getting there
I have to quote Warren Zevon
send Lawyers Guns and Money
Mr chair I I have the roll call sheets
so that in an emergency once we get
representative walber on line so we can
see his face and he can vote
um if it helps I can record on the roll
call sheets and then give that to him
and to you okay
he still needs to be able to vote Yes I
understand that but in other words we
might he might be able to get his
face but not have all the
um additional tools he would need
to record the Roll Call yeah
just an offer
I appreciate it
of all the times
okay
Jen what's the number that Kurt can call
maybe they can help him connect
so we're not holding everybody up
um I'll just need just a second to look
at the calendar just a minute
yeah she's getting it hold on one second
okay
um so if you need to dial one nine two
nine
two zero five
six zero nine nine
and enter webinar ID number
-3326
.
all right he's going to call
um
that number and see if they can help him
get connected
but I mean he just nothing he can do he
doesn't have he doesn't have electricity
I'm sorry I just gave you the number for
him to connect to the meeting by phone
is that that that's what I thought he
wanted that's why I gave you the webinar
ID nope I need the number that he calls
for if there's a problem and you can't
connect I wanted to see if someone can
help him talk him through it to connect
that would be me
271-3099
-3099 all right let me call him back
we could wait uh we could
uh we could go ahead and
the representative Smith taking votes
and recording them but unfortunately
that always representative wolper out
and unable to vote
I don't know if you want to
take a recess let's say until two
o'clock and come back and
and reconvene
rather than us all waiting here
that's something you'd prefer to do
see if we can get represented so we're
in the voting modes well I mean are we
in the voting mode because there's a
motion on the table so I'm not sure if
we are allowed to recess right yet we
may have to vote on this one and then we
can recess
I think
I don't think we've started the vote yet
the Kurt the confusion started because
when Kurt we really realized Kurt wasn't
there to take the vote I don't think
the actual starting of the vote voting
okay cool and yeah
we recess until two o'clock and maybe uh
Kurt can get up and be available to us
and then other people we can get some
other other things done in the meantime
all right thank you okay why don't we
recess till two o'clock you would too
thanks thank you
foreign
thank you
cool
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
so I've been working with representative
welper he's been able to connect to the
meeting twice
but he hasn't been able to maintain the
connection
so he's going to be trying one more time
I'm keeping an eye out to see if I see
him come in as an attendee
um
but that's the status for now he's got
all his settings right he can do it
it just sounds like a weak connection
all right
Mr chair yes
um good afternoon are you having a good
time
so far I knew you were I
um had occasions since I had idle time
to talk with the clerk
um about the question that came up
earlier when representative Kenny wasn't
sure how to proceed and what the clerk
said is that uh the correct terminology
would be to say
I move or to pass
and I have an amendment
and handling it that way we get both the
auto pass and the amendment on the table
and then the first
discussion of course would be on the
amendment
and um but that is the way to handle it
and I
thanked him for that and I thought I
would share my new knowledge
sharing
I think it's being two o'clock I uh
I'm hoping that we can get Kurt
connected if we can't get him connected
the one thing that we do need to do
today is get out before early bills
so we'll deal with the four early bills
if he's unable to participate is going
to be unfortunate but I really don't
have a choice since they need to be
reported out no later than this Thursday
yeah
and Mr chair it's representative Smith
again causing trouble for you right now
I I have
I have a problem
um I think we can vote on a lot of bills
and it would be sad not to have
representative wolper involved but I
have a moral
problem with us voting on any
Reproductive Rights bill without
representative Loper being present
because it is
um Central to his sense of his
role as a legislator and I believe that
there are
um
uh
so that's I just want to listen
what I see him
while Iron's hot right okay okay let's
go
I'd like to thank Marjorie very much for
those words I appreciate what you said
and I'm sure we all agree with them as
well
the uh
[Applause]
so uh we've been having our discussion
on uh on cacr6 we were about to vote on
that representative Walker
I heard some of that
and I have a role
in my face almost
so I yeah
the rest of us were ready to vote on
that uh would you are you at a point
where you have an executive
oh
representative wolper are you at a point
where you could vote on CS at six
yes
first of all
would just like to have some information
for my own
our records
adopt the amendment that was gonna
right we were voting on the amendment
I thought the motion was Mr chair ought
to pass as amended by zero two nine one
h
am I correct
I think we vote on the amendment first
and then we vote on
ought to pass as amended if the
amendment is adopted correct
yep I wish I could
do this
you need to do a roll call to adopt
the amendment we need to do a roll call
to adopt the amendment if in fact we're
going to do that
if you have an otpa I guess you do I
don't believe you do I don't care we'll
do it no you adopt the amendment what's
the amendment number
what's the amendment number nine
oh two nine one
0291h
um roll call sheet
oh nine two one
the clerk will call the roll oh two nine
one
two nine one not oh nine two
okay I got that right
uh
when the amendment took out the
executive Council
that's correct and governor
uh so
I'm an 0.921h
and
do we lose Kurt again
yeah no he's there okay
I'm calling the rule I have to use my
phone
I don't dare put my phone on Bluetooth
because it's connected again
so I have to to my ear in order to heat
here and when I vote I will hold me and
you can see me at the time
but to do this my ear
we're not hearing you Kurt
where are we
I think when you have the uh you were
unable to hear you at times for some
reason
thank you
what would you like me to do
uh well we need you to call the roll if
we can hear you call the names
excuse me
I mean Mr chair uh earlier on uh
representative Smith said that he she
had the sheets so
would it be more workable
so that representative wolfer could
participate
right actually uh the way it's working
right now maybe
we could have her call the roll on the
sheets and representative wolper could
listen and record
for me
okay
so representative Smith would you be
willing to do that it would be my honor
to thank you Mr chair
um the uh question before us is on
Amendment zero two nine one H to cacr
six and the clerk's assistant is calling
the roll representative McLean no
representative Sylvia no
representative welper
perhaps we'll come back to
representative Alexander yes
representative rice
no
representative Silber no
representative green no
representative Kelly no representative
tausch
yes
um representative traudia
no
um representative Smith votes yes
representative Birch yes representative
Harrigan yes representative De Lorenzo
yes
representative Chase
that was a yes from her thumbs up
okay representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative uh Simpson
yes
uh back to representative welfer
foreign
can you hear us
um representative Gordon
uh no
um
okay
and we still don't have representative
Welker
for votes no
representative welper votes no
um
Mr chair the vote is
eyes and nine Nays and so
the motion passes
so the amendment is adopted so we're
back to the bill
ought to pass as amended
the question before us Mr chair is
ought to pass as amended on cacr6 as
amended by zero two nine one h
uh
further discussion representative Sylvia
yes I'll be uh voting no I think uh this
has been in law for quite a long time
and there's no need to change it now and
it also brings up a question about
sheriffs who would then be
in their own little category
any other discussion
okay we will take a vote and
representative Smith representative
Chase
can you hear me
yeah I hear you now okay
just have a quick question on would uh
representative Sylvia just said so
sheriffs I know we discussed that but
they're the same as a judge their
contracts are the same
so can we even change one without
changing the other
yes yes okay thank you they're covered
by the same article the Constitution but
now that our constitution will have two
different age limits if this goes to the
home thank you thank you
are you ready are we ready
representative Smith would you call a
role and uh for our Clerk
on behalf of uh the clerk
um representative McLean Mr chair no
yeah Kurt walpers not visually uh here
Kurt you need to uh
need your make yourself visible
if you can hear it chairman Mr chairman
there he is
okay
okay uh Mr McLean I mean representative
McLean
no
um representative Sylvia
no representative Welker
representative welfare can you signal
yes or no
may we come back to representative
welfare
uh no Representative welper no
representative Alexander oh no
representative rice
no representative Silber
oh
representative Greene no
representative Kelly no
representative tausch now representative
trottier
now
representative Smith votes yes
representative Birch yes representative
Harrigan yes representative De Lorenzo
no
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny
yes
representative blindly
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson
yes
um and the chair their boats now
um
Mr chair the vote being
um nine years and 12 Nays the motion
fails
thank you is there another motion I see
your hand up representative McLean
yes thank you Mr chair I move itl
representative rice
second
and seconded by representative rice
and any other discussion
representative Horrigan
um I opened the Nord to say I think
probably
um
retaining it would have been a better
solution than itlling it at this point
just because uh
doesn't nobody is going to vote on it
until November 2022 anyway so even
though we're
even though we don't want to have any
more retained Bill hearings as well then
we have to
um that might be that uh that might be
the best solution at this point
um but
we do have a motion to vote on yeah and
representative Alexander
um thank you just to um uh respond to
representative Oregon I think the
committee or um at least part of the
committee understands that there's
really no compelling need right now and
the sponsors did not outline a
compelling need to um pass this right
now so I don't even think retaining this
um would help solve the problem so I
urge the committee to vote itl
and there is
and there is a similar resolution being
considered in the other body
I
okay are you ready to vote
okay again
on behalf of the clerk I call the role
representative McLean yes we're missing
the clerk again yeah we're
representative wolper doesn't appear to
be
there here we go there we go we're back
again okay representative the motion is
itl representative McLean
is um yes representative Sylvia
yes representative Walker
the motion is itl could you signify with
your hand
if that's acceptable to everybody
what
appreciate it uh
then I mean yeah
okay I I believe the representative
um welper has voted yes saying no to the
bill yes to the motion
uh representative Alexander yes
representative rice
yes
representative silver yes representative
Greene
yes representative Kelly yes
representative tausch yes representative
trottio
yes
representative
um
representative Smith votes yes
representative Burch
oh
Marvin Birch
no
representative Birch votes no
representative Harrigan uh no
representative D Lorenzo yes
um representative Chase yes
representative Kenny
no
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
now
and uh the chair
boats yes
um Mr chair the vote is
um 17
uh yays and four no's the motion of itl
passes
okay we have decided to make that as a
committee itl and representative McLean
you're going to do a committee report
yes sir and we're going to need that
soon so I can get it to the clerk
tomorrow
and
what we'll do next is we'll do we're
going to do the four early bills just
until our next
Calamity occurs
I was Bill 420. foreign
[Applause]
apparently somebody must care
representative McLean
I'll move on to pass
oh
a second
representative
okay
and would you like to address your
motion representative McLean
um I I just think that um
[Music]
right now we're in a place where we're
trying to build up trust uh between the
police and the community
um this I think is a good thing and we
want to I think eliminate the illusion
if there's any policing for profit going
on here
um the amount of money that we're
talking about is
um not a huge amount of money so um I
think if there are any drug programs
that you know might be in Jeopardy that
are funded by this they could be made up
by other means but the most important
thing for me is building up that
relationship between the police and the
community
representative Horrigan
um yes I just believe the opposite I
think
the uh generally the police uh during
the level of trust between the police
and those who police is not as high as
it should be but I still think um the
current program is a good one and I
think this is the appropriate use for
that small and somewhat very amount of
money I.E to use it for uh
prevention and also for uh for
enforcement and so there's a
I think that's this isn't uh the need
for treatment a lot larger than the
small uh there's a small fund so I don't
think we should uh rate it just for just
for the treatment we should have
different sources and more uh more
stable sources for the treatment so um
I'm gonna
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm going to go
ahead and oppose this off to pass motion
this is yeah this is the same bill we
had a rather memorable floor fight where
I think they called for a roll call and
I was on the itl side they got 19 votes
and uh but I'm still undeterred I still
think the other 18 members you voted
against it were right and
okay
any other discussion
um yeah
Mr chair I'm confused
um I listened to what representative
McLean said
and
because I hold him in such high regard I
take what he says
with a high degree of support but
if I understood correctly
he moved
ought to pass
on a bill that is changing
the way
we do things
um
and yet he spoke as if
we were keeping in place the way we were
doing things so clearly I'm confused and
I need help
you're going to Mclean do you want to
address that
yeah certainly
um the the intention of this legislation
and I wasn't at the public hearing
unfortunately because I had to introduce
a different Bill and a different
committee but as I understand the intent
of this bill is to take the money that
is collected seized and to put it into a
place
a drug a forfeiture fund
that
the the police would not have access to
and it would be used for drug treatment
and so because of that
um it is basically an independent fund
and what that does is that eliminates
the perception of any policing for
profit or anything of that nature
um and so that is how I read the bill so
that is a departure from where things
stand right now and that is why I'm
supporting the bill I hope that answered
your question uh representative Smith
thank you very much
I just want to add I was one of the
three that voted against this bill in
the last session
uh it it passed and uh as I said I was
one of the three that voted against it
and
my recollection in the last session was
we had testimony particularly from the
Nashua police and being supportive of
the police
they said this bill was all about us
being able to interdict drugs coming
over the Border yes
that was their testimony but when we
heard the testimony from the people who
opposed it from the police that opposed
it this year it's all about the money
that we give out to other Charities as
opposed to money that they were using
for their police effort so
um I
I guess I found myself torn on the bill
this year as to whether that's
appropriate
representative Birch
thank you Mr chair
um it's my reading of the bill that
there's no mandatory
change of spending in this bill this
bill does not require one single extra
dime to go to uh mental health core
mental health or social programs or the
like
so
um it may be aspirational but I'm not
sure it accomplishes what what good
representative McLean suggests that it
will do
okay yes representative Langley
um thank you Mr chair
um yesterday in the meeting I I spoke in
support of this bill and I guess for my
colleagues I think I had this confused
with one of the other bills I'm going to
vote to oppose this bill and the reason
I am is because I'm concerned
that using this money which I agree with
representative McLean is a
small a very small amount of money and I
don't want it to be seen as a mechanism
ultimately that could be used to fund
some of these programs that are
desperately in need of funding but not
tiny bits of funding there are need
they're in need of substantial funding
and I would hate to see it used as a
mechanism that just was suddenly going
to be uh of
considered a way to support those
programs so thank you
any other discussion on the bill
I guess you're ready to vote so the
motion is an occupast motion
and
representative Smith again would you be
willing to call the roll my pleasure on
behalf of the clerk hold up hold on I
think we need to get Kurt on camera here
if we can
together
Kurt are you out there
Mr chair should I can call the roll and
come back to representative Welker
I think
um I think we need to do that actually
if that's acceptable to everyone we
won't
he won't vote until we see that lovely
face representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia
uh yes yes
um representative Alexander no
um
representative rice
yes
um representative silver yes
representative Greene yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tash
yeah
representative Trott here
no
representative Smith votes no
representative Birch no
representative Harrigan uh no
representative De Lorenzo no
representative Chase no representative
Kenny no
representative blindly no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no representative
Simpson now
um
uh representative welper can we see your
face
[Music]
pardon me
um Mr chairman I hate to interrupt but
um
Aaron Goulet
informed Ann Fitzgerald that should he
not be able to get on video on Via video
the speaker's ruling is that since his
identity was verified when he was on by
video this morning and lost service due
to inclement weather he will be allowed
to participate the replacement policy
will be updated to reflect this one
exception for everyone
um could I ask what one exception for
everyone means this I guess what I just
read that
I don't know all I'm telling you is what
I was told I'm just reading it word for
word
yes he still needs to be able to vote
right he needs to be able to hear us but
if his video this is what
um and maybe Jen can verify that with
Anne so that I'm not like the lone
person saying this well I don't think
anyone questions your veracity
representative
I know but I would just you know people
wanted to say this a representative
welper
can you hear us
I'll try to
um representative Gordon
yes I mean and Mr chair do you vote the
clerk will go yes on it no you mean the
clerk is voting yes oh no no the chair
is voting yes the chair is voting yes
okay
um
uh
and the I would report the
the assistant clerk here would report
that there are 14 Nays six yays and one
um not voting
representative wolper just joined us ah
representative wolper
the vote is the motion before us is
ought to pass on 4 20.
um do you vote yay or nay
and we can't hear you so you'll have to
use your hand signal up or down use your
thumb up or down
thumbs up up thumb is up okay so it that
would make it seven years and 14 Nays
and the motion fails
is this another motion Mr chair
is there another motion sure
who would make the motion oh I'll go
ahead and do it then I'll move expedient
to legislate
representative Horrigan moves in
expedient to legislators seconded
seconded by representative Simpson yes
and do you want to address your motion
briefly well pretty much the same
rationality gave for voting it's the
ought to pass this is a um
this is a small amount of well first
it's a fairly small amount of money
that's uh it's mostly huge for uh
for prevention and then interdiction
which I think is you know it's still uh
which is still still necessary and it's
uh mostly correlated with how much uh
prevention the interjection is going on
so treatment is a separate issue I don't
think this uh amount of money would make
much difference in the need for
treatment which is also a fairly
politically popular cause and something
that's uh problems with Ronald retriever
not really because there's inadequate
money available for it except but so I
think this is a relatively small amount
of money that can be targeted by the
Attorney General to where it's uh most
needed to
stop the supply and stop the demand up
front and so that's um that's why I
that's why I'm proposing this itl motion
any other discussion are you ready to
vote
I think we're ready to vote on that
um Mr chair of the motion is itl on 420
and standing in for the clerk who
appears to on our screen twice
um yes yes well the clerk is on the
screen twice because his power came back
on all right and so now he has uh Power
to his laptop and he's still young his
phone which is constantly connecting and
disconnecting but this seems to be a lot
better oh great
um do you want me to continue to take
the role or do you want to
um
that's a fair question what are we at
we're at uh
and I took TL vote on 420.
on 420.
okay let me just see if I can do this
real quick because I should be able to I
have all these files of at least this
one available so I'm happy to do it
while you get organized representative
all right go ahead
um okay IPL on 420 representative McLean
no
um
representative Sylvia no
Representative welper no
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
representative Silber no
representative Greene
yes
representative Kelly
no
representative tausch
yes
excuse me yes yes thank you
representative
um Tradio
yes
representative Smith votes yes
representative Birch yes representative
Harrigan yes representative D Lorenzo
yes
representative Chase
I'm doing that to 420. yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Langley yes representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes
and Rick and the chair there was no
the chair votes no
okay Mr chair the vote is 15 yes
six no
um on the motion of itl carries
and representative Harrigan
um made the motion right representative
Horgan you need to do a committee report
if you could get that to me
by tomorrow morning that would be
greatly appreciated okay no problem
um I don't have the I don't have the
form but I can do 420. there really is
no form just if you send it in send an
email that's all I really need okay with
the report representative Horrigan yes
email with the report yeah
and
house bill 481.
and Mr chair I think representative
Macbeth had a question well I'm sorry
representative Macbeth
thank you Mr chair and it's um I just
wanted to stay for the record I know I
can't change my vote but at cr6
um I believe I voted yes for the itl I
had intended to vote against it I was
voting for the um um Amendment and for
the ought to pass as amended but I think
it was an itl if the if the record can
reflect that fine if not uh as far as a
note from the chair but um thank you
uh
can that be changed if it hasn't been
reported out of committee yet uh yes
I believe it can yeah oh thank you if
and what would that make the vote if I
recall
fourteen seven
thank you very much
um Mr chair
House Bill 481
establishing the office of the right to
know Ombudsman and making an
appropriation therefore
in
representative wolper did you want to
make a motion on that I would like to
move on to pass on House Bill 481 Mr
chairman
and is that seconded
seconded by representative Lang uh uh
actually yeah representative Langley
okay
[Applause]
can I do that I can do that right
and do you want to address your emotion
representative Wolford
thank you Mr chairman House Bill 481 is
uh been it was a subject of a long
Summer's work by the uh uh right to know
Commission
it's uh
hoped to be
really good solution to the inability of
our citizens
to uh get information uh that they need
from their local communities their
boards and committees
we currently have a very the only way
when when a cool request is made by a
citizen the only way of
disputing
or or uh yeah disputing a refusal
is to go to court and this is very
intimidating and expensive and difficult
and well beyond the means of most of our
citizens the Ombudsman is uh hoped to be
is a solution that's been used in many
other States including the neighboring
state of Maine
where his uh reportedly working quite
well
and created an initial surge of cases
which has since declined to a much more
acceptable level
and most of the disputes are easily
resolved and we're hopeful that that's
exactly what the Ombudsman will do at
very little cost
to the state the uh
office space and things like that are
within the budget of the Secretary of
State who said he could handle that very
easily
we'll uh have people who have
volunteered to volunteer
to do it so the salary expense will be
you know or very near
and the cost to the cities and towns of
these lawsuits can be enormous it was a
suit in uh sandwich was 250 000 dollars
when they lost we've heard lots of
testimony from people that there's this
towns have spent twenty thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars defending suits
that probably didn't need to be brought
if everybody had
a better understanding of the right to
know law and and an authority figure to
guide them as they go forward uh it's
hope that it and it's part of the
ombudsman's tasking
to give us reports so that we those who
write and supervise this law
will know uh what's causing disputes
what kinds of uh issues are where the
law is vague or faulty and correct them
expeditiously
so all in all it should be an excellent
solution for our state and practically
no cost
and fully supports the uh intent of our
city 91a
the other discussion on the bill
yes representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chair
um
I think this is a bit of a unicorn uh
this is a government solution it's uh
solving a government problem our
weakness in 91a is not going to be
resolved by adding more government to
the issue
if this
happens to work out I'll be happy to eat
my words but uh
three or four years from now when the
bureaucracy is built and it just won't
go away and people still have their
problems with 91a and
I'll be happy to have a dinner of crow
D
Lorenzo sponsor of the bill
thank you Mr chairman
um just to address representative
Sylvia's concerns about the unicorn and
all other kinds of stuff um there is a
um sunset provision to the bill
um so if it doesn't work there is a
there is a way to make it go away
I have invested a lot into a lot of time
into this bill a lot of effort along
with representative welper
representative um Hopper and a few other
people and um we we really feel that
this is a great solution for New
Hampshire
and as far as cost
um the salary will
there will be a salary there won't be
volunteers acting as Ombudsman so and
that that's really important that we do
have a salaried position that way um
there's
um oversight and
professionalism
if anyone has any questions I'd be happy
to help to answer thank you thank you
are there any
questions or further comments yes
representative Langley
um thank you Mr chair I would just add
I've had experience working with
Ombudsman when I was the director of
adult and elderly services and I I think
to um representative Sylvia's point one
of the things that I saw that I I didn't
expect quite frankly was having
ombudsmen available to people in in
facilities I saw them able to intervene
before a problem became catastrophic or
before it became big enough that it had
to reach the absolute top of an
organization and that's one of the
things that I think this Ombudsman
Position will add to us because of their
familiarity with systems and on their
ability to talk with people and being
more approachable to people I think they
are often able to intervene in ways that
um are really quite effective thank you
any other discussion
say none are you ready to vote
I think we are so representative wolper
we have
emotion about to pass
and would you like to take the role on
the motion representative wolfer I I
would love to take the role in about
10 seconds
all right we'll do it a different way
ah take this
House Bill oh look at that that's what I
want House Bill 481
ought to pass
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia no
representative well proposed yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice
yes
oh
where am I
come on
representative Silber no
representative green now
representative Kelly
no
come on move
get is that doing to me
representative Tosh
representative trottier
now
representative Smith yes
representative Burge yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative D Lorenzo
yes
representative Chase yes
cut it out
just leave the door open
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman yes
all right so what do we got we got
one two three four
whoops that's a no
five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
in divine
to five
motion carries
right
is will it be a Minority Report
yes there will be okay
I need and that will be coming from you
representative Sylvia
yes
and representative wolper you'll be
doing the majority report committee
report again if you could get that to me
by tomorrow morning that would be
helpful
I will be done tonight sir thank you
and Minority Report by tomorrow morning
okay and moving on to house bill 596.
thank you
for everything Public Funding of
abortions establishments
[Applause]
representative trotty are you going to
make a motion on this
yes I was I'd like to make a motion um
Mr chair to itl please
and I'll second it
is that representative green
yes
so it's moved by representative trottier
seconded by representative green to make
this in expedient to legislate
and do you want to address your motion
Mr trottier representative trottier
excuse me
mute
you're a muted representative
talk about that Mr chair after reviewing
this bill I feel that it's lacking
information
um some of it is the financial part also
on the pack of
um
establishing the Adoption Fund
I understand it saying that it's going
to um be funded during donation through
through donations and things like that I
just don't think there's enough
information for us to proceed forward at
this time with this bill
thank you any other discussion
if not we appear ready to vote
so Mr Clark could you call a roll uh
take me a moment and then I'll be ready
while he's doing that I neglected to ask
on cascr 6 if anybody wanted to file a
Minority Report on that
funny Macbeth did you wish to do so
yes I will thank you
again if you could get that to me
tomorrow that'd be great
the same is true of Representative uh of
rep of house bill 420.
that was the goal with regard to
forfeiture does anybody want to file a
Minority Report on that
foreign
so we're on
House Bill 596 with a inexpedient to
legislative motion
are you ready uh the clerk is ready in
expedient to legislate on house five
Bill 596 representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia yes
Clark votes yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
representative Silber no
one two
whoops that was a no
one two three one okay representative
Greene yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith yes
representative Birch yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman yes
uh the vote is 20 to 1.
and move consent
without objection
and we'll place this on the consent
calendar
and
that brings us to
to
um
house bill 622.
[Music]
representative Alexander do you want to
make a motion
um yes I do Mr chair I want to make a
motion to retain
and is that seconded
yes I'll second it Mr chair
second advice
representative karate here
any discussion
yes um give me one sorry about that
so um the committee heard has heard
multiple bills regarding
um this subject and um the bill would
protect fetal life at viability which is
defined by Planned Parenthood V Casey at
23 and 24 weeks but I think there is
value in a bill like this however we've
already we will be voting on another
bill and I think
um these both accomplished nearly the
same thing so I'm asking the committee
that we retain this bill so we can see
the direction of other bills that we
might have on our agenda thank you
yes representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chair yes there
are a number of other bills and they are
the same bills that we hear year after
year after year
and um they are emotional bills they are
bills that are distressing to people no
matter how they feel and I don't
understand why we would retain this bill
rather than act on it
um as we have year after year after year
and I would oppose retention and hope
instead that we could consider another
motion thank you
thank you
and if there's no one else that wishes
to speak then I'll call upon the clerk
to call the roll this is on the motion
of retention
just one moment Mr chairman please and
we go here we go delete that okay
on retention of House Bill 622
we need to scroll just a bit
don't stop representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes
clerkbots yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice
yes
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith no
no representative Birch
no
representative Horrigan no
representative De Lorenzo no
representative Chase no
representative Kenny
no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman yes
I have an 11 in the affirmative 10 and
negative
motion passes
[Applause]
and
you um I guess I would ask the committee
if you want to address the remainder of
the
abortion related bills right now and get
them taken care of
excuse me I
chairman I hope
and I have half hour before I have
another meeting that I've already pushed
off
um can we see how much we can get done
in a half an hour by any chance
as opposed to with other bills you mean
is that what you're asking
okay
[Music]
representative Smith
um
it's your call Mr chair I doubt if
there's going to be extensive debate on
any of these bills I think
um
people know how they're going to vote
um and uh so it's just a question of
whether you want to go through the
remaining bills in order or not that's
completely up to you I just as soon get
the abortion related bills out of the
way at this point in time in our early
session if we can why don't we do 625
House Bill 625
and I guess I just wonder I just want to
um
I'm going to support whatever you want
to do Mr chairman out of respect I just
want to register
my objection to us not going through
these bills in the order that I mean you
had begun by saying we would go through
them in order then you said we do the
early bills and now you're picking these
bills out and there are
ramifications for when in fact these
bills will get to the floor
um and uh so that I would prefer that
you just go through them in order but
having said that I will of course
respect your decision
well I was hoping to get through the
mall today and my intention was to go
through an order just as you said but
unfortunately we had a technical
difficulty today so then I felt that we
needed to get rid of the early bills
which we clearly needed to do and now I
find myself with relatively limited time
any at this point in time and so I'm
going to do these bills I think and I I
understand your objection and I
appreciate that representative Smith but
I'm going to go forward with house bill
625.
and and thank you and I and I just want
to be clear what you do understand what
my objection is
why
I'm saying this
well what I heard you say was the timing
of these bills apparently has some
importance to you or other people and
uh I get that okay then I would just
like to go on record
um as you all know
um at the moment
um there is a case pending in federal
court that might make it possible for
there to be a full participation of all
legislators in the sessions on the 24th
and 25th if however that doesn't come to
pass there will be a number of
legislators who will not be able to be
there on the floor on the 24th and 25th
but perhaps might be there the next time
we meet in full session and these are
important bills and that's why I thought
we should just take them as they come
and not
um pick and choose but now I've I've
voiced my concern and I respect your
decision thank you thank you I
appreciate that representative rice
would you like to make a a moment where
you raising your hand to make a motion
on 625
yes thank you Mr chairman I move on to
pass
I'll second that Mr chair
and was that Mark
yes sir okay moved by uh representative
rice seconded by representative McLean
and with a motion of octopass
you want to address that briefly
representative rice or do you just want
to sure I think 24 weeks is plenty of
time to
to self and
um and there is a provision for
significant health risks so I ask that
you support this bill
and is there other discussion today
if not are you ready to vote
if so
Square can you call the roll
momentarily Mr chairman
let's go to the other window please
ought to pass on House Bill 625
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes
represent Court votes yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice
yes representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh yes
representative trottier
yes
[Music]
representative Smith no
representative Birch no
representative Oregon no
representative Lorenzo no
representative Chase no
representative Kenny
no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth
representative of Macbeth votes no
representative page no
representative Simpson
no
Mr chairman
I have the Warriors
uh 10 to 11. the motion fails there are
another motion
thank you very much
um Mr chair
um I uh uh vote I move itl on House Bill
625. and I seconded by who
um seconded by it looks like
representative Chase is Raising her hand
thank you
you want to address your emotion briefly
representative Smith
um
I'll I'll take the time
um no I there's no need to take the time
um I will address it
when it's appropriate right now we can
just go to the vote
okay
and the clerk would you like to call the
roll
uh momentarily Mr chairman
momentarily scroll yeah
the boy uh
foreign
can I
uh
all right let's try it this way
so I want you to know that I'm having
some more less than a little fun here
okay representative McLean now in
expedient to legislator on high school
now
representative Sylvia no
the court votes no
thank you
representative Alexander no
representative rice no
representative Silber no
representative green no
representative Kelly no
representative Tosh
how
what happened
the keyboard doesn't work representative
trottier
representative Smith yes
representative Burge yes
representative Horrigan
representative Oregon
representative Oregon voting or am I
just deaf no I don't know what he's
doing he was signaling up
thumbs up from him
okay thank you
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
where am I at Chase
representative Kenny
yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman yes
time the vote as 11 to 10. you know
motion passes
will it be a Minority Report if so who's
that who's going to do that
I'll do that
representative rice we'll do the mine in
the morning
but if we do uh next uh House Bill 434
thank you
and
representative Bryce since you're still
here do you want to make a motion
um I'll move OTP
and is that second to representative
Mr chairman
is there an amendment on that
um yes Mr chair my hand is raised to
move amendments
okay
so they're they're right now we have an
ought to pass
motion from representative rice seconded
by representative trottier and
representative Alexandria Alexander do
you wish to make an amendment
um yes Mr chair thank you I actually
have two amendments would you like me to
move those separately
yes uh they do two different things yes
they do I guess you would
okay great
um Mr chair I'd like to start with
moving amendment number 2021-0338h
um and the committee should have
received that via email
um last Friday
um but if you want I can send it to the
committee again
and I'd like to speak to it
does anybody want him to resend it or
are you all set why don't you speak to
it sure
um so the sponsor
um suggested that this amendment be
offered
um that would help solve a couple issues
with Federal funding
um
so I just urged the committee to vote
for this
um that song would say on that
okay
any other discussions on the amendment
seeing none
just clerk if you could call a roll on
the amendment and the amendment number
is
we're working on it Mr chairman zero
three three eight
oh I just do it the other way
ah this is not fun and
okay
well that's amazing
huh
adoption of amendment 0338
to house bill
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia
yes
the Clark both yes representative
Alexander yes
representative rice yes representative
Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Tosh yes representative trottier
yes
representative Smith no
representative Burns no
representative Oregon
I got it I hear him representative De
Lorenzo
no representative Chase no
representative Kenny no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman yes
okay we
what's the vote
I don't know I haven't figured it out
yet 11 to 10.
yes the one is 11 to 10 the adoption the
amendment is adopted okay without the
that Amendment representative Alexander
did you say you had another amendment
um yes Mr chair thank you I'd like to
move Amendment
um
2021-0339h and I'd like to speak to that
okay and is there a second to that
motion
seconded by representative rice
and you can address your Amendment
um thank you Mr chair so
um this amendment is very simple on page
two
um
online 17 and 18 it removes the lines
um or for training to provide or perform
abortion the reason why I wanted to
remove that line is because I want to
make sure that even though I don't
necessarily agree with that abortion
procedures in all situations
um I think that we need to set our
nurses up with the proper Educational
Tools to be successful
um in this state and whatever they
decide to do in the future so I just
think this gives you an H or other
university the university system options
on educating on medical procedures that
are performed in this state on a regular
basis
um so for that reason I I hope the
committee will adopt this
um I did speak briefly to the university
system lobbyist who said that this would
help alleviate some of their concerns
with the bill so thank you Mr chair
any other discussion on the amendment
um
it would have been I would have
preferred the amendment that just
strikes this language altogether because
um certainly it does solve one problem
I'm not sure
what the rationale is for not letting
individual students decide how to use
their um
how to use your fees which are uh for
the most part uh
most part paid by the students
themselves or by other
rather than buy a rather than out of
taxpayer money so the purpose is to
prevent attachment running your future
I'm not sure why we're including the
tuition and fees very little of which uh
is actually in fact paid for by out of
the state tax monies
so
um I'll vote against this on the grounds
it doesn't go far enough this entire uh
this entire section of the bill didn't
belong there in the first place plus I
mean I'm opposed to the whole thing but
um this
elimination one problem but it's still
like leave several other problems in
place so
is there any other discussion
seeing none Mr clerk could you call the
roll uh would you give me the amendment
number again please Mr chairman oh three
three nine
the amendment 0339
we're going to change the number from
eight to nine get in there
Mr chair uh
representative McLean 0339 yet a doctor
no
yes
representative Sylvia yes representative
clerk both GS
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly
yes
representative Tosh yes
representative trottier
yes
representative Smith no
representative Birch no
representative Horrigan no
representative De Lorenzo no
representative Chase no
representative Kenny no representative
Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman
yes
the adoption the amendment is adopted by
a vote of 11 to 10. right so we're now
as with a ought to pass as Amendment
with the two of them I need a moment Mr
chairman right I'm just going to ask if
there are any additional amendments
good
I see none and
so I think we can vote on the ought to
pass as amended
[Applause]
foreign
338 and 339 on House Bill 434
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia yes
clerk votes yes representative Alexander
yes
representative rice
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith no
representative Birch no
representative Oregon no
representative Delorenzo no
representative Chase no representative
Kenny no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman no
I have the voters 10 to 11.
oh the motion fails is there another
motion
representative Smith yes Mr chair I
um move itl on House Bill 434
is it seconded I'll second that seconded
by representative Chase
you want to speak at all to your motion
or just maybe just go forward I think we
can just go forward with the vote at
this time I think we can go forward with
the vote
representative uh wolper almost ready Mr
chairman
uh
uh so we're doing
itl on
represent on four three four and three
four as amended
oh well no it'd just beyond four
I guess I guess it one three four
yeah that's right the way I have it
representative McLean
no
representative where am I representative
Sylvia oh wait a minute I gotta do this
no I can't do this this is too
complicated I'll get confused
okay so we got representative Sylvia is
a no
Clark is a no representative Alexander
no
representative rice no
representative Silber no
representative green no representative
Kelly no
representative Tosh
no
representative
trottier
now
representative Smith yes
representative
to put there on the wrong line yes I did
I better take that out I have Mr Troyer
voting twice hang on just a second
all right and we get them only once
representative Birch yes
[Music]
what cut it out
okay representative Oregon
yes
representative De Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman
yes
so the vote is 11 to 10.
and who would do The Minority Report on
that
uh I think I will
just to be clear Mr chair The Minority
Report is going to be an otpa correct
otpa 338 339 yep perfect so for those
that don't know
if you report in a committee report the
amendments
the Amendments appear in the calendar
along with the bill
so they will both be there and subject
to separate votes in the house
I'm sorry to interrupt but it may be
necessary to have those amendments come
by
combustion
um your preferred minority motion is
otpa you may need to have those combined
into a new number
yeah it's my understanding that
legislative services does that and
they'll give it a new number yes
okay that would save time but it would
save time if the itl doesn't pass right
off the bat but yes
okay why don't why don't we do uh House
Bill 233
[Applause]
and
this representative rice do you want to
make a motion
Mr chair yep I'll make a motion on this
bill is it a lot to pass
okay
[Applause]
and who seconded that
representative rice
and
okay and do you want to address that at
all representative green
uh just briefly uh during a testimony
the operative phrase that came out to me
is medically appropriate
that if the infant is born regardless of
circumstances
that
it's medically appropriate that if it
gets reasonable care and treatment so
I'm I remember I asked my colleagues
about autopaths thank you
any other discussion
thing then I think we could vote on the
ought to pass motion and that's the odd
to pass motion the house bill 233 Mr
Clerk
working on it
oh I got a little call don't I
okay that's all right let's go over here
um
I don't know what I'm doing doing too
many things
foreign
I don't know what's going on here
we all had our fill of technology today
chairman as while we're doing some
housekeeping I got two spam things in my
spam folder one supposedly from you via
Dropbox and one from Karen Karen what is
the sake or something with a flowchart
attachment and I wanted to know if
they're real or spam
the Dropbox for me is real it should
include an amendment to house bill 227.
and Mr
yeah
I um to respond to representative
sober's question I emailed back Karen
and she confirmed that that is a
flowchart of our bills that has been uh
it's legitimately
um
devised by the committee and sent to us
thank you
I have a housekeeping issue with my um
my Dropbox is at a link to a Dropbox
that has an email address that's
neither of the addresses that's listed
the legislative uh
uh legislative um
my legislative activity so it's all if
you do Mr chair is hopefully just you'll
get an email back from Dropbox and you
can say that you approve that email
address as one of the ones that can read
your your thing you dropped in your
Dropbox so um I I will I'll send the
amendment out and then he's not voting
this afternoon which I think or not it's
not it's not a matter of great urgency
but it can make more work for you but
that's about it that sounds here okay Mr
chairman I'm ready to uh take a roll
call on House Bill 233 ought to pass
hey we have a motion about to pass in
hospital 233 and Mr Clark take the role
representative McLean yes representative
Sylvia
yes work folks yes representative
Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes representative
Silber yes representative green yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Tosh yes representative trottier yes
representative Smith yes oh excuse me no
representative Burge no
representative Horrigan no
Representative durenzo no representative
Chase
representative Chase
and she's signaling no no
Kenny no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth
no
representative page no representative
Simpson
no
Mr chairman no
I have devoted as 10 to 11.
and is there another motion
uh Mr chair I move itl
representative Smith moves in expedient
to legislate seconded by representative
Chase
and I think you can just take the vote
represent representative Walker
just a moment Mr chairman I want to do
this in a way that's not so confusing
for me
so this is House Bill 233
itl on House Bill 233 Representative no
uh representative Sylvia
wait a minute I'll mute my microphone
here
oh I can't I can't call the roll on a
mute microphone sorry about that
you're on your way out
that's why he's excited
uh where was that representative
representative well-provoked snow
representative Alexander no
representative rice no representative
Silber no representative green no
representative Kelly no representative
Tosh
representative trottier
now
uh representative Smith
yes
representative Burge yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative ding Lorenzo yes
I lost my spot I can't see in the names
get the road or right representative
Chase yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Langley yes
representative
yes representative page yes
representative Simpson yes Madam Mr
chairman
yes
unsurprisingly the vote is 11 to 10 and
the motion passes
and 433 can we do that
wow where is it oh who would do The
Minority Report on 233
nobody
um no
31. I'll do it representative Wolford
okay and and 4 30.
let's go 4 30 which is the buffer zone
bill
I move ought to pass
I second representative McLean moved out
the test
seconded by who was it representative
green okay
come on you want to address it at all uh
representative McLean you're just going
to get the executive summary for time
basically there are some constitutional
concerns
um but it hasn't been implemented um in
all the time that the law has been
enacted so I think taken as a whole
um that this bill has Merit
thank you
folks ready to vote
you could call the roll and not to pass
the chairman
[Applause]
ought to pass on Hospital 430
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia yes
core quotes yes
representative Alexander yes escape from
that you silly guy are you
foreign
[Applause]
yes
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith no
representative Burge no
representative Oregon no
representative Lorenzo no
representative Chase no
representative oh I put that in don't
you voted twice representative Lorenzo I
probably you know both times
representative Kenny
no
representative Langley
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman no
you get in the box I have the voice 10
to 11.
and is there another motion
Simpson
representative Simpson moves
I'd like to move in Expedia into
legislate
and seconded by
executive representative Chase
you want to address that at all
representative Simpson
if we need to move on for time we can
um
if we want if you want me to take a
moment just to address representative
McLean's concerns that he brought up the
the bill is a flexible law that allows
or the bill that's in place now is a
flexible law that allows for it to be
implemented and I think in the interest
of concerns we've heard about increasing
um
and threats to leave the bill in place
um the buffer zone Bill we have now in
place to allow for the flexibility of
clinics and Healthcare centers to
address any issues that come up is
important
um the bill has withstood
challenges in court and uh
I think tries to balance the First
Amendment issues as well as the public
safety issues involved
okay
representative
I'll
I'm sorry representative Horrigan I'll
take a moment to say like and I I didn't
have that much to do with it Reverend
Birch was
had more to it anybody but they're about
half a dozen members totally rewrote
the original Bill four or five years ago
so we were
well aware of the of the McCullen versus
Coakley case so we we tried to read the
objections raised in that one and also
um
the activities of the protesters
some of them say that they're offering
counseling services so there actually is
no First Amendment right to offer
unlicensed Counseling Services on the
sidewalk or anywhere else and this does
it also
and in terms of free speech just doesn't
uh limit the right to free speech it
just means they uh can't do in a way
that's obstructing or harassing people
who are exercising their own rights to
uh obtain a legal medical service so
that's I just thought I'd make those two
points um
but
um
anyway because I think any on this bill
anyway it's unnecessary at this time
anyway so let's let's itl it and thanks
okay there's a motion of inexperiod to
legislate and
made by representative Simpson seconded
by representative Chase and Mr Clark do
you want to call the roll no but I will
uh representative McLean
no
representative Sylvia
quick won't snow representative
Alexander now
representative Bryce no
representative silver no
representative green no
representative Kelly
no
representative Josh no
representative trottier
now
representative Smith yes
representative Birch
where did he go
he's there yeah
representative birds are you living
but I can't hear you yes yes yes
representative Oregon thank you yes
representative domarenzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
Kenny yes
did you call me
I can't hear anything
I hear you looks like he's Frozen
yes
representative
can you hear I can't hear anything
what happened
Diane it's not you Kurt's Frozen oh
kirkus oh so you can hear me
loud and clear yeah yeah you're fine
I'm sorry I didn't I thought you
couldn't hear me
given today you knew if he froze it
would be in the middle of a boat of
course
Mr chair if I could pick up after
representative Langley
you can uh representative Macbeth
yes representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
and the chair yes
um Mr chairman the vote being 11
to 10
um the uh IPL motion passes
okay
and a Minority Report who might be doing
that I'll be doing that Mr chair
representative McLean
let's see if there's something we can
agree on
there's a house bill 331
or if you're a property bill
and I understand that there might be an
amendment and some type of an agreement
would be on this matter
yes I have uh I'll move what to pass and
offer an amendment to HB 331
presented Sylvia lose ought to pass and
is that seconded by representative Burge
seconded by silver
silver yeah
get away
with all due respect I have to leave
okay thanks so much you guys do you mind
if we go and vote on 331. do what you
have to do I I just have to go to this
other meeting thank you thank you
representative rice
huh
Mr chair
yeah 331 I believe is the one where the
amendment went in the Dropbox so I was
unable to access it no no no 227 is the
Dropbox all right thank you thank you
for clearing that up this one was sent
out quite a while ago okay
okay and representative Soviet do you
want to uh you're moving that you're
moving on you've moved out to pass
and now you want to offer an amendment
is that correct yes I'd like to offer
Amendment zero one eight eight each
sponsored by myself and representative
Burch
what was the number of that Amendment
zero one eight eight h
thank you
and you want to address that sure I'll
uh cover it briefly this uh Amendment uh
settles a long-standing dispute uh
perspective problems that uh
representative Burch and I have had
uh we uh we seem to be uh kind of
speaking uh across each other and not
quite uh understanding where we're at so
the issue was having to do with the
federal Joint Task forces
and
um this bill makes clear that
uh
it only applies to seizures that are
done by local New Hampshire law
enforcement uh in the state and it does
not affect Joint Task Force seizures
so as a reminder this bill
uh prohibits the
um
adoption to the federal Equitable
sharing program of uh seizures
under one hundred thousand dollars
and keeps that in state we have a good
criminal asset Orchard
law interstate
this keeps that uh from going into the
regular program
and uh
that way we are assuring that the the
state law is
followed and we have
a criminal prosecution and money is not
just uh
uh taken through a civil map process
thank you
representative Birch did you want to
address it at all
I think it's a uh it's a good Amendment
it clarifies exactly what we're speaking
about it's not a huge sum of money but
I'm glad to support it
any other discussion
okay we'll be voting up voting on the
amendment to
House Bill 331 Amendment 188 and Mr
clerk could you call the roll
[Music]
um I could call the wrong
and we but I appreciate the number once
again oh 388
no oh one eight eight H is the amendment
the bill is 331. all right
and okay Amendment 0-1 oh I didn't put
it in there Why didn't it put it in
there
come on come on
0-188
Amendment adopt a Monroe 188 to House
Bill 331 representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes clerk both yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice
say again do you left
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith yes
representative Birch yes
representative Oregon yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth
oh yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
represent uh Mr chair
yes
I have the one at 20 to zero
okay that brings us to the original
motion of ought to pass with the
amendment 0188
and is there any discussion
if you're ready to vote Mr clerk you
could
clerk is opening the file to do the
other roll call
where'd he go how come this already says
that
okay
thank you
ought to pass as amended with house
Amendment 188 uh and House Bill 331
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia yes court books
yes representative Alexander no
no
representative rice is not here
representative oh wait a minute I just
put that in the wrong place I'll fix it
right now yes
can we
uh no
can we representative silver yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith yes
representative Burge yes
representative Oregon no
representative diorenzo
yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
Mr chairman
I have devoted 18 to two
you've adopted
House Bill 331 as amended with Amendment
and
uh with me a Minority Report on that
Mr chair I'll defer to my friend in
Durham but I don't plan on writing one
um and consent is okay with me I would I
was going to defer to my friend from
Goffstown and uh so I guess we're both
in agreement we don't objective putting
it on consent so
okay that'll be on the consent calendar
without objection
okay House Bill 232
to pass
second
by representative Sylvia ought to pass
and who seconded that sober
representative Silber seconded that
and would you like to address the motion
sure just briefly uh this bill uh takes
uh property
negotiations
uh for Price leaves that in non-public
but then uh
makes the actual consummation of the
deal uh a public matter
so I think this is a good public policy
to make sure that we don't have things
like that went on in Laconia
and of course that's when we found out
about we don't know if other such deals
have happened
in non-public sessions so I think this
is a good policy for us
any other discussion
I
I listened to a discussions on with Tony
and I gathered that not everybody was
happy with the decision was made in it
they did this often happens in real
estate negotiations uh
you know lay the groundwork for it in
Secrets I I
don't really see what the larger problem
is it seems like a local controversy
which uh
and I don't think if this bill if it law
had said would have said I don't know
that would have happened that really any
differently substantially so that's uh I
I just I think this bill is unnecessary
and I don't think the story about
Laconia proved that it was necessary
anybody else
do
you seeing none
we have a motion a lot to pass on House
Bill 232
and
I used to work in Colorado
hospitals 232.
representative McLean
yes
where am I representative Sylvia
yes representative Alexander yes
is Enterprise is not there
representative Silber yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative Smith no
representative Birch no
representative Horrigan no
representative Dino Renzo no
representative Chase no
representative Kenny no
representative Langley no
representative Macbeth no
representative page no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman
yes
thank you
motion fails on a 10 to 10 vote
I'm wondering if we want to uh rather
than take another motion at this time to
hold the bill until
we have a full complement of
members
yes
okay I would not object to that Mr chair
thank you representative Smith
so
maybe move on to house bill 566.
[Music]
that
um
and we may find ourselves in the same
circumstances on that bill
[Applause]
you um
would you like to do House Bill 359
perhaps we can come to some agreement on
that today
[Applause]
or a motion on 359
they're two hands up it's your call Mr
chair
I'm gonna call in joke I think uh
representative Alexander first
um
thank you Mr chair
um I make a motion to itl um hp359
and is there a second on that
I'll second it reckoned by
representative silver
um
and do you want to address that at all
representative Alexander
um I I mean briefly we can I think this
bill does have merits but I also think
that the sponsor
um also admitted that there's a lot of
problems with the language in this and a
lot of the answers
um to the questions that the committee
had uh were not answered so I just I TL
it and bring it back as a new bill
um might be the best way forward
any other discussion I I guess the
question is whether or not you I T L it
based upon that or whether or not
um
clearly the sponsor indicated that it
was poorly worded and and
it needed work
either
I tell it or you could retain it I guess
one of the other
me yes representative Simpson I'm sorry
question is whether if this isn't going
to pass if it's something that we can't
retain because it heard a lot of
testimony that it does seem to address a
problem that is happening in New
Hampshire and I from what I heard it
didn't appear that the problems were so
difficult to solve that we couldn't
um do so with some retention and
conversation
representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair just to address
that point
um the sponsor and advocates for the
bill gave examples of how the 11th
Circuit Court
um in the South
um struck down um discrimination this is
being discrimination based on race
um but we have no evidence up here that
the Circuit Court up here
um would do the same and I think that
this bill the merits of the bill would
qualify in my opinion under
um definition of discrimination based on
race so I think for that reason
um we we should ideally
representative Smith
thank you
um Mr chair I um
as we all did sat through that hearing
and I was quite attentive as I try to be
um uh to all all the bills and I was
um saddened
by some of the questions that were asked
that to me
um would if I were an attorney and we
know I'm not would cause me to say I
rest my case the questions themselves
reflected
um
uh what could politely be called
unconscious bias
uh uh where perhaps the speakers didn't
quite realize the implications of what
they were saying I believe this is a
problem that is experienced here in New
Hampshire and that the least we could do
is address that problem either by going
ahead with the bill or in good faith
retaining the bill to try to correct
some of the um
the drafting weaknesses and then go
forward with the bill where proudly we
could say that yet again we're
respecting the rights of all the people
in the state thank you
representative Morgan
um yes if we the Full House
and the Full House passes an Ito then
that would make it difficult for
someone to introduce a similar Bill next
year because we've already rejected it
so um that's uh that's a potential
disadvantage probably a person would be
uh I'm sure Reverend waltz or the other
issue support would probably not
introduce the exact same bill given uh
you know since they were at the hearing
and they were uh
they heard those same concerns we were
expressing at the executive sessions so
I think um it only it might be
potentially problematic although that's
like a
particularly case of what judgment the
deputy speaker makes this fall and then
it can also be appealed to the rules
committee if somebody wanted to bring
the bill back after it I was itl but
that's just the next few issue with
doing that versus taking some other
course like moving forward with it so
um so that that's that's just what I
have to say about it I think I think
it's a I think it's a good idea I do
agree there's the way it's worded is uh
not really not not really ready to be
passed
well I think that's my issue is
um you know I'm sympathetic with the end
of the bill but the way it's drafted you
you know you can't really Define Race by
someone having the characteristics of
race
you need to have a an appropriate
definition and it's just poorly poorly
drafted poorly worded and it needs it
needs work
[Music]
I certainly I don't think it's in a in a
state where it could be passed or should
be passed at this point
okay if there's is any other discussion
this Mr chair
would the maker of the motion uh
consider withdrawing itl so that we
might uh
instead uh introduce a motion to retain
I don't know you could ask
representative uh Sylvia if uh
excuse me if Alexander would be willing
to do that
um certainly uncertainly willing to do
that on out of courtesy to my friend
from Durham
um we also
um don't have a full committee here
today
um
and circumstances may have been
different
so and representative silver would you
be amenable to withdrawing your second
in order to continue yes that's that's
fine
and is there a motion to retain them
so representative Alexander would you
make a motion to retain the bill
sure I would love to
so moved
and seconded by
representative Simpson
and the clerk can call the roll
momentarily Mr chairman
as well as you don't mind a little
squeaking in the background oh not at
all
hey I'm retaining Hospital
entertaining House Bill 359
representative McLean
yes
representative Sylvia
representative
representative Alexander yes
representative rice who's not there
representative silver yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh yes
yes representative trottier
yes
representative Smith yes
representative Birch yes
representative Oregon yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase
yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman yes I would order 20 to zero
who will be retained
where we at
okay
foreign
any further this afternoon my concern is
that many of the votes that we may take
at this point in time are going to end
up being 10 to 10 votes
um what about 287.
uh well 287 is the remote notarization
you know
I know we could
uh
we we could vote uh
to read and I don't know where people
are necessarily on it we've been asked
to hold the bill by the bankers
Association because they're trying to
work out the details and we were asked
or specifically requested
uh to hold the bill because they're
trying to amend the bill in the Senate
there's a similar bill in the Senate and
it's been made part of an Omnibus Bill
but the current bill doesn't provide for
remote notarization of estate planning
documents like Wills or trusts and
they're looking to amend it there
and hopefully when the Senate Bill comes
over but they've asked us if we would
hold that bill for now if that was
agreeable to everybody
until we see what the Senate does
are they assuming that the Senate is
going to vote on that Mr chair and get
it to us before we are expected to vote
on on it
I'm not sure that they will get it to
yes that's the intent is uh actually I
I'm not sure that they're actually
looking for them to vote on it as much
as they are to see whether or not they
will in fact amend it
in the Senate
thank you
I can make a motion to retain it
I think we need a full committee before
you proceed
yeah I think that would be a good idea
um
I
I think when I look at the rest of the
votes that we have
and the indication where I think people
will be on either side of it I think
we're going to end up with a lot of 10
10 votes and I just don't think that's
in anybody's interest right now
Sylvia yeah I'm I believe HP 360 is
surprisingly easy have we not dealt with
that yet
we haven't dealt with that yet
HB 360.
oh
if we heard
it I thought the issue with HB 360 was
that uh Elliott Berry was gonna
um provide the committee with um uh
updated forms which I don't think we've
received yet
he he actually did send
yes
uh and I actually uh spoke with him and
he resent it to me yesterday so
it hasn't been drafted yet but he does
have an amendment to the bill
so we don't want to act on it now right
I don't don't think so I wasn't planning
on it
okay
so
I I guess I'll do what people want to do
if you want to go forward and plow ahead
with some of the other bills that are
pending probably doesn't make sense
I don't think it does right now I think
we should wait and have our full
committee to do that
then we can have some definitive votes I
you know just based upon
uh the conversations that we've had and
you and I have had representative Smith
I I just think that we're gonna
find ourselves divided on virtually all
of the remaining bills
well perhaps in the fullness of time
um the scales will fall from some eyes
and will agree on one side or the other
I'm always optimistic yeah
yeah so I didn't say whose eyes I just
said eyes
the only thing that I request is that
people do need to do those committee
reports if you made the motion today the
successful motion today uh with the
exception of the retained bills I do
need
I do need committee reports
and I don't want to have to haunt me
tomorrow
yeah
and with that I guess I will
close our unless there's other business
people want to bring up yes
representative De Lorenzo oh thank you
Mr chair
um would you believe that I made an
error in voting I
amendment to cacs six I intended to vote
in favor of the amendment
okay
I
I if it hasn't left the committee yet I
think
that can be that vote can be changed
do you know what the updated vote is on
that
um representative Smith the vote count
I'm just looking now 17-4
because Becky changed hers too
I just want to make sure I have it right
for the final action report that I give
to the committee assistant
well but but they
are you changing on the cacr or on the
amendment to the cacr yeah
on the amendment
[Music]
I don't have I don't have the vote on
the amendment I have the vote on the
bill itself
12 yes
yeah that's what I have too well to nine
on the amendment and then
um but that had
um
on that Becky was Voting yes and
Charlotte was Voting yes
so yeah 19-2 so did you want those to be
changed or those stay the same
just the ones on the amendment oh change
the bill was voted in expedient to
legislate in any event right right
could very well be moot but yes well I
so so on the final bill itself
was it 17-4 still or was it uh it was
still 17 to 4.
in expedient to legislation right thank
you
you're welcome
okay
any other business
Mr chairman I just asked if you and
representative Smith would stay online
for a few minutes with me after we get
done
I would be glad to thank you
and I'm assuming representative Smith
would as well I would and I just I think
probably representative McLean should
stay also
you should
and I just want to thank everybody for
putting up with what we've done today
with the issues that we had
I wish I feel badly that we had to face
the challenges that we had to do today
but it went very I mean I still think it
works better
this way with nobody in the State House
um it the only problem today was Kurt
and that had nothing to do with
the state as it probably had to do with
Comcast or somebody like that you had to
do with the tree branch
well it interestingly uh
the the we had that terrible day where
we had the the computer kept breaking
down in room 206 208
and then we came in for the next hearing
date and we didn't have a problem and I
talked to the tech people and they
actually said that they changed the
machine out from 206 to 08 and put it in
enough another room and gave us the
other machine
and so our machine went better but but I
understand representative hunt broke
down the next day so yeah
this
anyway
thank you thank you all so very much I
really appreciate it and thank you for
being so uh respectful and courteous
today for everybody
and we'll see you see you Friday
your Friday take care bright and early
bye bye bye